[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
um
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
what's going on
[Music]
[Music]
like it's really loud
[Music]
uh
[Music]
so we're going to get
[Music]
dies a lot what's up oh sending love for
the wild oh yeah yeah said no love for
the wise old gamer man he's going
through it right now
so salute to him so yo oh cat daddy
what's going on
got the future of the round with him you
know what i'm saying little
from the legendary north dallas man as
we come back
so salute that brother and we will
return
here you hear you man welcome to the
show if you would not
mind go ahead and uh find yourself a
spot get comfortable grab a snack
do all that good stuff that we need to
do and um you know we're about to get
started i am well it's not important who
i am
uh what's important is that you are
pulling up to the iron lords podcast
right now as we speak and uh i guess i'm
here to keep you entertained until it's
time to get this show started so um
turn me to an animal and haters be
swearing they real but come to find out
that they really mechanical and yeah
i'll be eating these rappers but that's
all a part of me being accountable
and they say i'm better than money
because you can bank on me being
accountable i know a million rappers
that don't wanna be on a song with me
that's understandable i kill a beat and
they wanna compare me to freddie and
jason i'd rather be hannibal they'd be
like why use a video game
just be original y'all so dramatical i
know it's random but i am addicted to
flipping the sample and making it
flammable this is that okay
this is the yoga fire flame they think
it's arson up in the apartment they call
the department and i get the blame still
i'll be running collecting them rings
you're just a target when i'm in the
range i was the hardest to start
regardless back with messaging people
check my vocals all on twitter but i'm
anti-social love
[Music]
to boil you ain't gotta say it i'm
embarrassed for you always been a nerd
never been a loser making voltron with a
gang of cougars and i'm going places
better tell an uber cause it's pretty
hard to sleep on freddy krueger
let's do that again hear you hear you
man welcome to the show
if you would not mind go ahead and uh
find yourself a spot get comfortable
grab a snack
do all that good stuff that we need to
do and um you know we're about to get
started i
am well it's not important who i am uh
what's important is that you are pulling
up to the iron lords podcast
right now as we speak and uh i guess i'm
here to keep you entertained until it's
time to get this show started so um
look y'all messed up and turned me to an
animal and headless be swearing that
real but coming to find out that they're
really mechanical
and yeah i'll be eating these rappers
but that's all a part of me being
accountable
and they say i'm better than money
because you can bank on me being
accountable i know a million rappers
that don't want to be on the song with
me that's understandable i kill a beat
and they want to compare me to freddie
and jason i'd rather be hannibal they'd
be like why use a video game
just be original y'all so dramatical i
know it's random but i'm addicted to
flipping the sample and making it
flammable this is that
this is their yoga fire flame they think
it's arson up in the apartment they call
the department and i get the blame still
i'll be running collecting them rings
you just a target when i'm in the range
i was the hardest to start regardless
back when you was messaging people
check my vocals all on twitter but i'm
anti-social love my city but i'm still
by coastal
[Music]
never been a loser making voltron with a
gang of cougars and i'm going places
better tell her uber cause it's pretty
hard to sleep on freddy krueger
let's do that again here you hear you
man welcome to the show if you would not
mind go ahead and uh find yourself a
spot get comfortable grab a snack
do all that good stuff that we need to
do and um you know we're about to get
started i
am well it's not important who i am uh
what's important is that you are pulling
up to the iron lords
podcast right now as we speak and uh
i guess i'm here to keep you entertained
until it's time to get this show started
so um
look y'all messed up and turned me to an
animal and haters be swearing they real
but come to find out that they really
mechanical
and yeah i'll be eating these rappers
but that's all a part of me being a
cannibal
and they say i'm better than money
because you can bank on me being
accountable i know a million rappers
that don't want to be on a song with me
that's understandable i kill a beating
they want to compare me to freddie and
jason i'd rather be hannibal they'd be
like why use a video game just be
original y'all so dramatical i know it's
random but i
when i'm in the range i was the hardest
to start regardless back we was
messaging
[Music]
i guess you could say that i'm very
spoiled but i'm gonna be your dog thing
very loyal but i ain't gonna hold you i
ain't here to boy you you ain't gotta
say it i'm embarrassed for you i've
always been a nerd never been a loser
making voltron with a gang of cougars
and i'm going places better tell her
uber cause it's pretty hard to sleep on
freddy krueger that's
do that again here you hear you man
welcome to the show
if you would not mind go ahead and uh
find yourself a spot get comfortable
grab a snack
do all that good stuff that we need to
do and um you know we're about to get
started i
am well it's not important who i am uh
what's important is that you are pulling
up to the iron lords
podcast right now as we speak and uh
i guess i'm here to keep you entertained
until it's time to get this show started
so um
turn me to an animal and haters be
swearing they real but come to find out
that they really mechanical
and yeah i be eating these rappers but
that's all a part of me being
accountable
and they say i'm better than money
because you can bank on me being
accountable i know a million rappers
that don't want to be on a song with me
that's understandable i kill a beating
they want to compare me to freddie and
jason i'd rather be hannibal they'd be
like why use a video game just be
original y'all so dramatical i know it's
random but i am addicted to flipping the
sample and making it flammable this is
that
this is their yoga fire flame they think
it's arson up in the apartment they call
the department and i get the blame still
i'll be running collecting them rings
you just a target when i'm in the range
i was the hardest to start regardless
back we was messaging people
check my vocals all on twitter but i'm
anti-social love my city but
[Music]
ain't gotta say it i'm embarrassed for
you i always been a nerd never been a
loser making voltron with a gang of
cougars and i'm going places better tell
her uber cause it's pretty hard to sleep
on freddy krueger
let's do that again here you hear you
man welcome to the show if you would not
mind go ahead and uh find yourself a
spot get comfortable grab a snack
do all that good stuff that we need to
do and um you know we're about to get
started i
am well it's not important who i am uh
what's important is that you are pulling
up to the iron lords
podcast right now as we speak and uh
i guess i'm here to keep you entertained
until it's time to get this show started
so um
look y'all messed up and turned me to an
animal and haters be swearing they real
but come to find out that they really
mechanical
and yeah i be eating these rappers but
that's all a part of me being
accountable
and they say i'm better than money
because you can bank on me being
accountable i know a million rappers
that don't want to be on a song with me
that's understandable i kill a beat and
they want to compare me to freddie and
jason i'd rather be hannibal
rings you just a target when i'm in the
range i was the hardest to start
regardless back when you was messaging
people
check my vocals all on twitter but i'm
anti-social love my city but i'm still
by coastal
[Music]
um
[Music]
very loyal but i ain't gonna hold you i
ain't here to boil you you ain't gotta
say it i'm embarrassed for you i always
been a nerd never been a loser making
voltron with a gang of cougars and i'm
going places better tiller uber cause
it's pretty hard to sleep on freddy
krueger
let's do that again here you hear you
man welcome to the show
if you would not mind go ahead and uh
find yourself a spot get comfortable
grab a snack
do all that good stuff that we need to
do and um you know we're about to get
started i
am well it's not important who i am uh
what's important is that you are pulling
up to the iron lords
podcast right now as we speak and uh
i guess i'm here to keep you entertained
until it's time to get this show started
so um
look y'all messed up and turned me to an
animal and haters be swearing they real
but come to find out that they really
mechanical
and yeah i be eating these rappers but
that's all a part of me being a cannibal
and they say i'm better than money
because you can bank on me being
accountable i know a million rappers
that don't want to be on a song with me
that's understandable i kill a beat and
they want to compare me to freddie and
jason i'd rather be hannibal they'd be
like why use a video game just be
original y'all so dramatical i know it's
random but i'm addicted to flipping
up in the apartment they call the
department and i get the blame still
i'll be running collecting them reigns
you just a target when i'm in the range
i was the hardest to start regardless
back we was messaging people on
[Music]
say that i'm very spoiled for them to be
your dog thing very loyal but i ain't
gonna hold you i ain't here to boil you
you ain't gotta say it i'm embarrassed
for you i've always been a nerd never
been a loser making voltron with a gang
of cougars and i'm going places better
tell her uber cause it's pretty hard to
sleep on freddy krueger
let's do that again here you hear you
man welcome to the show
if you would not mind go ahead and uh
find yourself a spot get comfortable
grab a snack
do all that good stuff that we need to
do and um you know we're about to get
started i
am well it's not important who i am uh
what's important is that you are pulling
up to the iron lords
podcast right now as we speak and uh
i guess i'm here to keep you entertained
until it's time to get this show started
so um
look you gotta mess up and turn me to an
animal and haters be swearing they real
but come to find out that they really
mechanical
and yeah i'll be eating these rappers
but that's all a part of me being a
cannibal
and they say i'm better than money
because you can bank on me being
accountable i know a million rappers
that don't want to be on a song with me
that's understandable
i kill a beat and they wanna compare me
to freddie and jason i'd rather be
hannibal they'd be like why use a video
game just be original y'all so
dramatical i know it's random but i am
addicted to flipping the sample and
making it flammable this is that
this is their yoga fire flame they think
it's arson up in the apartment they call
the department and i get the blame still
i'll be running collecting them reigns
you just a target when i'm in the range
i was the hardest to start regardless
back when you was messaging people
check my vocals all on twitter but i'm
anti-social love my city but i'm still
by coastal
[Music]
i'm embarrassed for you i've always been
a nerd never been a loser making voltron
with a gang of cougars and i'm going
places better tell her uber cause it's
pretty hard to sleep on freddy krueger
let's do that again here you hear you
man welcome to the show
if you would not mind go ahead and uh
find yourself a spot get comfortable
grab a snack
do all that good stuff that we need to
do and um you know we're about to get
started i
am well it's not important who i am uh
what's important is that you are pulling
up to the iron lords
podcast right now as we speak and uh
i guess i'm here to keep you entertained
until it's time to get this show started
so um
look y'all messed up and turned me to an
animal and headless be swearing they
real but come to find out that they
really mechanical and yeah i be eating
these rappers but that's all a part of
me being accountable
and they say i'm better than money
because you can bank on me being
accountable i know a million rappers
that don't want to be on a song with me
that's understandable i kill a beat and
they want to compare me to freddie and
jason i'd rather be hannibal they'd be
like why use a video game just be
original y'all so dramatical i know it's
random but i'm addicted to flipping the
sample and making it flammable
this is their yoga fire flame they think
it's arson up in the apartment they call
the department and i get the blame still
i'll be running collecting them rings
you just a target when i'm in the range
i was the hardest to start regardless
back when you was messaging people on
aim
check my vocals all on twitter but i'm
anti-social love my city but i'm still
by coastal
[Music]
you ain't gotta say it i'm embarrassed
for you i've always been a nerd never
been a loser making voltron with a gang
of cougars and i'm going places better
tell her uber cause it's pretty hard to
sleep on freddy krueger
let's do that again here you hear you
man welcome to the show if you would not
mind go ahead
[Music]
imma just chill and watch them any
snacks in the attic i wanted to chill
with the pack and be like a young wolf
but then they would mistake me for
addict if i can imagine it's cool to
give you some advice and invite your
girl to your squadron
cause if you don't give her that option
you're gonna be single player like siren
you're gonna get tossed in the bushes by
king david
royalty and not a pretender detrimental
to an elemental what's an avatar to a
knee bender i gotta be me though
i know it's my destiny word to kind of
who cares if you fly if you steal a
mosquito you swear you ain't something
but really
you like to collect stuff and that's
cool but i got bad news
even if you really was that jew king
david still be the king of the statues
since the juvenile i've been cursed with
a curse to be musical and if you hate it
we'll meet in the crucible wasn't it
nothing is cool and it's beautiful we
let you know that your dreams are
pursued but whatever you want to do then
it's doable if you got work on a sunday
it's suitable cause you can listen to
this in your cubicle
on the lord's day
if you got work on a sunday it's
suitable cause you can listen to this in
your cubicle on a lord's day
[Music]
all right hear ye
hear ye hear you and we
are live welcome to the iron lords
podcast and the lords of gaming.net
episode number 191 it's another glorious
sunday we're back at the round table on
the lord's day
i'm extremely excited about our very
special guest and we've got the x-com
franchise
and kymerus card discontinued ps4 models
nintendo and next level games and new
switch pro rumors to discuss
so we gonna get right into it but before
we get in how many times we would talk
about a switch program
so we got some super checks we got to
take care of you
that's okay and it jumped me why did it
jump okay i got it i got you i got it
uh we got night music with the four
dollar super chat good good afternoon
sir not good morning but enjoy your
coffee nonetheless
then let's welcome lord hollow to the
round put the crest in the crap
lord hollow and then we have our brother
tazo ichi with the 50 super chat thank
you so much
how the intro got horns who hit up scott
storch and squishy
i miss you all before the holidays happy
new years lords wish you all the best
and thanks for the entertainment and
escape when nyc tries to make
us crazy yes factual
no doubt we are we all yeah we're good
all right no doubt so let's get into it
man
so i want to introduce a lord whose
unique talents and programming and game
design
has quickly ascended him up the ranks of
the most iconic
turn-based strategy franchise in the
history of video games
introducing the lead designer of x-com
chimera squad and major design
contributor
of war of the chosen and the amazing
x-com 2 franchise
the super smash brothers savant and
affectionately nicknamed
lord lanky on most xcom live streams
live from baltimore and kind enough to
make his debut
into the realm of the lords my man
lord mark nordah of firaxis games how
you doing sir
guys it's good to be here thanks for
having me absolute pleasure man your
lord at what you do
pleasure to finally have you here in the
room what's been going on with you how
you been doing
what you've been playing what's been
going on with you man i've been good
we've been on been on a long break
fraxis has uh
had a nice winter break so um been
playing a lot of games because that's
what you do
now you can't go anywhere
i've been playing well i play a lot of
overwatch
with friends been playing some uh yakuza
like a dragon
um and i actually started up a new
divinity original sin two co-op run with
a friend because
you know always looking for more i have
a question i'll beat that game
eventually
one day i have a question yakuza
in game pass sir
no it's all right okay well you know you
purchase your way and you play your way
thank you
this is a guy advocate give the dab some
money
oh here we go here we go listen that
that's that's that's very valid
you know you can you can definitely
because they got that money up front but
you can definitely contribute to extra
that's
great i mean i'm not saying i didn't get
on steam sale but
i got i i got those the super special
edition just
solely for the extra karaoke songs
i cannot believe from that sentence i
like
i let kid smooth con me into buying that
game are you serious
yeah hilarious i mean that's larry and
man
it has a lot to it and that whole
karaoke joint that you could actually it
is i know it's lit
so a bit you got a little bit you said
divinity um
you're causing like a dragon those been
the main rotation
yeah i play some like more
multiplayer stuff here and there like
phasmaphobia or whatever or
jackpots or you know just so you i
actually interact with people
i think i've started divinity original
sin three times that i still ain't beat
that game
yeah man yeah i think you've only
escaped fort joy so many times you know
i got divinity too that's what the one
we're talking about
yeah my boy gifted to me so you ever get
a game that you didn't know
that you had to play because somebody
gifted to you so you're like
yeah let's go oh it's it's homework now
exactly like
that's all if you want to get a couple
super chats while we uh uh
yeah first off let's welcome to the
round lord dirty nerdy
andy crawley with the 10 super chat hey
brothers from other mothers
what a great way to start the afternoon
can't wait for my king
mug andy last week thank you i think i'm
so happy that you chose me
out of the vast selection of the lord
the fact that he bought your particular
cupboard i swear i love it
but if you've got any king t-shirts
please take those pictures
and send me a tweet savage service
man absolute pleasure to have you we're
gonna have some fun so let's get into
the rest of the show and you all oh hold
on we got to get one away get one away
good afternoon lord it's good afternoon
my brother
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah he's been we
got professional company he's different
now
we're back
[Music]
yeah i saw the intro of it yo
y'all better tune in y'all better buckle
up my man is ready yeah absolutely
dragon man much love
and you already know we got the four
horsemen of gaming those original lords
of the realm here at the round table
with our time
sensitive because we have a guest
updated intros
the difficult game conqueror lord of his
own world and the how
of the young wolf my man lord addict how
we doing sir
doing pretty good since we're time
sensitive that's all
that's all you're getting out of here my
man following
yeah that's that's that ravishing rick
rude
music and of course we have our most
technical gaming lord the solo gamer who
lives for the single player selfish
experience
and also the south stradamus the lord of
clarity and patreon of the iron bank
my man lord sovereign how are we doing
sir doing pretty good
uh chilling uh i was on a big cast
yesterday shout out to ainsley and
and the in the in the game we kept the
slander to a minimum
that's it i was driving my car listening
i know yeah
for that emmy uh panel one yeah when the
remake comes out the reflection
when you said you know uh i was like you
know i could go back and listen to that
at work today then you said
you guys are talking about you know red
dead now i've completely
it was not
[Music]
[Laughter]
we know where you live anything you've
been playing sir
uh yeah on the switch because i haven't
been able to really play on on the
console i got until the end on the
switch
it's fantastic and he's just kicking my
ass you're always
killing me i love it though brutality
was talking about it yesterday it's
fantastic um but it's beating me up
and then i downloaded something that
came out on apple arcade like last year
grindstone it was like the biggest game
for apple arcade
but of course i don't have an iphone so
i did it on the switch i paid the switch
stacks
but it's fantastic it is a fun little uh
kind of grindy game
but it's that's it no doubt no doubt
and of course we have the incredible
hulk of this
aka the access gamer
the prophet of xbox king of the statues
who demands nothing less than that
premium
experience it is the leader of the fraud
alert movement
ooh beloved lord king how are you doing
sir
you know what i'm doing yo listen i want
to give a shout out to smitty smith
i love you i love you first of all
um he super chatty yesterday i want to
give a shout out to everybody who came
out for those five hours i don't care
how long you say i don't care if you
stay for five minutes
i did two live unboxing shows one with
sideshows
and the next was the the big bucks was
xm studios if you see the red hulk he's
finally in the house nice the thing in
the fantastic fours down in the bottom
that red hawk is absolutely amazing
that's what i look like when we have to
do that 11 a.m stuff
that's exactly how i feel you know i'm
transforming and you looking like the
red hulk
um it was an incredible thing i want to
give a shout out to sick mansion please
everybody go to sick mansion
and uh subscribe this site if you don't
if you're not subscribed to dolph
castlex that's dcx that's what i do
on fridays at 9 00 pm every friday
that is the statue group we talk statues
we live statues we live comic books
entertainment and movies
make sure you go there and subscribe
yeah everybody that showed it it was it
was a beautiful thing
what i'm playing right now um i'm
odyssey
i said um
no that was a game that i purchased you
know yes you're right it's not a game
pass
i'm gonna get to a game pass game that
i'm playing right i'm trying to gain
pass shane
i pay my money for this continue there
you go yeah
right but um i heard a rumor oh so uh
the man is um trying to finish this game
now
before that rumor becomes official and a
game
launches inside game pass that forces me
to bend the knee okay
oh yeah um destiny i've been raiding yes
all this week iop clan is in
full you know it feels so good when i
see attic just popping my party for no
reason
and he knows that i'm invisible but he
knows where i'm at
so i love everything um i've been
playing cole vain
man and warhammer chaos bane
okay 60 frames per second
okay it's like diablo and and if you put
that field of view up proper and you put
the world in
in in all the you know whatever the x
can do
series x can do it is absolutely
stunning and amazing
a true rpg the story is dead
i'm like wow i did not know about this
and now they got a
fan so i'm going to purchase the game
because it was for free to play
this weekend so i said you know i'm
buying the game so guys
what's up no doubt and of course hold on
actually sorry you want to get that uh
super chat yeah so we have uh squirly
dan with the five dollar super chat the
world is the matrix and the iop is the
red pill
keeping it real let's go let's
is privileged to a lot of iop after dark
chat he's in our chat yeah and squirrely
is having a ball
he'll little mark's face
the next one from stitches for you oh
boy here we go
shout out to the little stitch with the
two-liner super super chat
[ __ ] have you gotten your eyes up
tomorrow yet no i have not
oh let me let me let me switch to the
iop account so i can block him
wait did stitch get it did stitch get it
i don't know but you
you use the words isaac tomorrow and if
i don't have one you get blocked yeah he
being real man how many guys have you
run this how many times have you run
i've done it 15 times so far
wow out of 100 people in a clan and we
run the deep stone [ __ ] raid in destiny
2 i think
i can name five people i know that
people that have it i know
that's one person back from the back for
dead he's in here he had it because he
was i was with him when he
got it who's this third person
i don't know i don't know baby snitch i
don't know so we'll salute salute him
oh of course let me get brat right quick
[ __ ] [ __ ] okay
podcast salute lords you already know
good to see you yeah bro
how that controller going stop being
messy
look man so look like i said a little
bit destiny for me um
obviously um no last word this uh this
week
unfortunately my brother e boxes texas
having a lot of internet issues so we
couldn't get the show going
so we hope to get king allen back he's
all the way from india
fantastic content creator we will get
that rescheduled
and talk about his history and all that
good stuff but um yeah that's
all i got but uh now that we've gotten
what the laws have been playing
i want to focus on lord martin order
his video game system history his
journey into programming and game design
and of course what led him to the x-com
franchise
and lead designer of that new
xcom universe of chimera squad
so lord mark let's start from the very
beginning what was some of the first
video game systems you had and what got
you into gaming
yeah sure um i don't think there's any
way for me to do this without
coming across as incredibly spoiled as a
child so
let's just get into let's get to the
bougie that's good yeah um
so it started when i was so i was born
in 89
so my gaming history started when i was
five and i got a second genesis
um because it does what ninten don't oh
let's go
there he go there we go let's get this
full fan boy out you're in the right
place
you're the right place what you're
saying gotta go fast
um so uh the first game i ever played
was
i like it was co-op with my sister we
played mickey mouse in the world of
illusion
castle of illusion baby oh is the world
of illusion or castle of losing
are there two no there are two
yeah there's two of them because i know
there was a fantasia game as well
right oh that fantasia game looked crazy
yeah yeah maybe i got my first game ever
played name wrong
there we go we fixed your history
[Laughter]
uh so yeah i played a bunch of genesis
games i mean
sonic obviously of course um vector man
um shining force too
[Music]
uh i mean i was probably too young to
know what i was doing in that but
you know the tactical routes early tied
the goobers um
then like let's see what other system i
have i had i had a sega saturn
i'm still going to take a train okay
okay so so question
was it a situation where like ninten oh
somebody i got to shout out someone for
the realm real quick oh shout out to
dirty nerdy getting the net gator for
the winter
protecting yourself you know what i'm
saying i respect that i respect that
yeah that looks good that looks good sir
but um i was gonna say so like was it
and then you didn't gravitate towards
nintendo
or like you you was like your parents
say i'm just getting you a sega
was that like how was that i i don't
yeah i guess my parents just
they just made the decision that i was
the second kid at some point
um i did play super nintendo and stuff
like my friends had super nintendo
um but that was the beauty about like
the older days
like your friends always had calls like
i feel like people don't deal with that
now because
like you know who who's really going to
they have their friends house these days
when they're younger to play consoles
i got a question i got a question the
first time you went to your friend house
because you had the genesis way before
he had a super nintendo
right and he was envious of you he was
over your house like oh my god this is
incredible
i don't have blast processing
so okay the first time you went over his
house and he put it on what was the
first game he put on
uh it was like super mario
world probably okay
swapped off
when you heard the audio chip and you
saw the the the
the scaling because they did the most
seven when you saw the multi-step
seven and you heard the audio chip what
did you say
did you have five well he was
when i
[Laughter]
[Music]
it was weird though like there were so
many like instances of like they had
almost the same games like the aladdin
game was like
different and like i had uh ninja
turtles in the piper stone heist instead
of turtles in time
which was like pretty much the same game
but yeah
you know they were stealing their
miniaturizing monuments or something to
steal them
i don't know um
i just wanted to know if you caught fomo
because when i first got it because i
had got the
the famicom version and i called you
know kyle go over to my house
so you know we sega nuts yeah and he's
like how is it
i said just get to my house
and he got there the fastest in the
world i don't know how you got he got
there
you're like he's like get to my house
and then you heard the door knock right
afterwards
yeah when he when he saw it it was a
thing it was a moment
so yeah yeah yeah my second loyalties
were tested
very strongly again i just bought seven
was was pretty it was
that's the only thing that we actually
king's asking you because mostly we felt
that the time was so transformative from
a scaling perspective
and at the time you know genesis was
known for the blast processing the fast
side scrolling and at least they had the
mature titles but i remember that was a
moment in gaming i'm like
this is something my console's not doing
you're right
looking to your history certainly uh
well yeah i had saturn which i don't
honestly remember that much like i play
i remember virtua on
was like my favorite uh-huh this is
solid this is awesome
i mean i had it for a while all right
guys i appreciate that
but then like the next generation i had
i had
ps1 and n64 and so
so yeah i was super spoiled playlist
nice um
what what extract what attracted you to
uh let's talk a playstation
first what what uh anything from
playstation that really stood out ps1
i think probably metal gear solid was
like my big
favorite i mean and i remember like
playing tony hawk a lot
when i was a kid for sure sure
tekken every time people talk about the
original metal gear solid and i look at
that game
i always think that's a bullet i dodged
[Laughter]
it was amazing for his time yeah i mean
i played twin snakes as well
we'll get to that later nice yeah on the
gamecube um
but yeah let's see i guess slightly
after that i did have a dreamcast which
i
loved and i was super sad that it kind
of had a short lifespan
um because like power stone was like you
know i love kind of like
fighting games but more the kind of i
guess brawley fighting games like smash
and yeah so power stone was like one of
the only other kind of things that was
doing something like that
yeah um nice nice nice let me backtrack
you to 64 for a second oh yeah sure
any n64 standouts that really has your
attention that really you put
hours of hours of game time into i mean
there's got to be a lot
like the i mean just like the big one
like mario 64.
uh ocarina and majora's
um me and my dad actually played a lot
of
pilotwings 64. because he was a
pilot at one point um
he was super i mean even though it was
like you're flying like gyrocopters and
jetpacks and stuff
so you still love that
what else i mean i'm sure there's a lot
more that i'm missing but i mean smash
64. that's what you already did the
savannah yeah
and i stopped one generation later you
know but um
yeah i mean 64 was just a great there's
like banjo-kazooie there's so many
classics of like it's kind of like
when i was the age where i remember the
most about gaming i think oh okay
yeah like that was like all like oh like
my childhood was kind of like
mario 64. you know gotcha gosh
this is amazing man a lot a lot of
diversity loving it let me just get a
couple super chats that we continue
sure i gotta want you to get what awaits
you sir yeah i got him i got one away
dragons with two dollar super chat
where is my damn iop help and destiny
hello man down somebody go back
need to be online sir yeah you need to
be online to ask for help yes
and then we have stitches in 2010 yes on
my third run so he got it on his third
row that'll be good
oh saluter stitch i know you got let me
get back coffee man salute to the
legendary
bad coffee giuseppe de vario man that's
from gears tactics fame man what it does
from gears to
splash damage he says salute to all the
lords great to see mark here and the
podcast always having consistently great
guests
salute man you know we gotta rep our
turn based on you know what i'm saying
strategy
games so we got to salute you guys but
yeah he was actually we had him on
as well tremendous history so we're
continuing so again you did
we have uh hold on this one yeah uh
michael aka bedsides finest ten dollar
super chat king make sure
cog don't start his middle ground talk
in my cog voice king
to be fair just because 900 000 ps blood
doesn't mean playstation is doomed there
are two million systems out there
that's not being messy salute to not
being balanced he doesn't want me
[Music]
god forbid not balanced
salute the best time to be a messi you
know i'm saying so salute
again playstation and 64. let me let me
ask you just a question a funny question
says you kind of had
a lot what did you have what
what systems you missed um i think
i i mean i didn't have the the older
nintendo's and then
kind of in the next generation like i
didn't have like i only had gamecube
from like kind of the first generation
of
i mean the the actually like powerful
console like ps2 and
xbox the original xbox obviously about
to say xbox one but that's not what
that's not yet um
so yeah i had gay but like that was
still in the time i was good i played a
lot of ps2 and xbox but
yeah i played a ton of halo but i didn't
have
xbox um
i kind of like knew pretty early that i
wanted to do something with games i
think from like
immediately like when i played
psychogenesis i was like this is it
that's what i want to do
was there a particular game though or
was just in general just the experience
in general
that was like okay i wanna because i'm
gonna transition but i wanna know like
was there a moment like what was the
specific moment or specific game you
said you know what
you know i wanna do this um i think
besides like kind of just the general
like video games being like
this is like my favorite thing like when
i was a little older
um kind of the mass effect series was a
big
oh boy well it was like really like
i i really like the whole podcast has
been d-rolled your podcast's about to
get the real because
well it was like there's this moment
where i was like oh like games can like
do something this big and like
meaningful absolutely you know beautiful
that i was like really
you know i i love it i love every single
one of them and like
but you have to keep your child lord
mark he he's but you have to pick a
child
and you have to you have to because it's
just a highly contentious thing on the
uh
a little podcast between myself and
solve the evil solve
all right i can give an answer i have
like kind of a conditional answer i
think
at the time mass effect 1 was my
favorite because it was like
totally different but upon refl and it
was like this huge thing that i've never
experienced but upon replay
we don't have to go into the room
clearly all right first impression
listen i mean not no not everybody's
right
you are welcome every time because i
just i just need you to repeat again
so at the time you were mesmerizing with
something different
mesmerized
as you got older you know what i'm
saying you started to realize how
great or superior mass effect 2 was to
mass effect
is that correct is that kind of accurate
am i like in the middle of something
i'm a bit surprised mark you know
because i you know as a as a as
i respected you i guess as a tactics
developer i would think that you you
know
you prefer the true rpg experience as
opposed to some
you know you know glorified action games
that's why
you should say that he likes sega he did
say that he likes glass master
processing and he did say that he was a
fast uh fan of gold fast
so through his credit he definitely
stood through the form
he saw it coming shout out what is next
time due to tactics games
sounds absolutely his gaming palette
matured that's just all it is
absolutely i mean i'm happy to be on a
mark nana talks about mass effect
podcast
we will definitely invite you i need i
need help dirty nerdy salute man he's
got the he's got the gator and he's got
the the pullover hoodie
for the winters he's he's right
oh oh he said the gator and the pull
over
oh you're gonna buy the scully cause if
you buy the scully they might arrest you
yeah you know you gotta gotta be careful
just make sure you're not doing any
illicit things listen you could be
walking down the street
i put on that gator and i have on that
the hoodie on
i mean uh the beanie on my head oh my
yeah all i ask is if you do anything
you know that we would frown upon just
just flip that logo
dirty if you're gonna do it be infamous
listen don't don't go all the way or
don't go at all
i'm done moving on inside you want to
get the super chat there
we got here we got um gabriel forte with
the five dollars if we chat
running all these raids and watching
everyone get what i don't have
24 clears and still no rocket launcher
maybe if i quit i'll get some love
i don't know you better be on after the
show all right
no doubt you already know so look man
completely completely understand where
you're coming from thank you for your
clarity on that
um but we got to move on as far as so i
get so we we got that
you know you said like those type of
experiences like the mass effect series
really influence you and say hey wow
games can do this
you know what i'm saying so that is kind
of what kind of inspires you so
what now led specifically now to the
journey as far as
just getting into it from um you know
just an educational standpoint what what
what route did you go
as far as getting into it game design
and programming sure
well i i think originally i didn't have
a clear idea of
exactly what i wanted to do in the games
i just kind of wanted to
i want to be part of it so i was like
well
programming is probably the best like i
was good at math and
logic and stuff like that so i started
high school like we didn't have a lot of
computer
science like it was pretty early in the
like incorporating
programming classes phase of school so
there was like one class so i did that
in high school
and then um went to college and got
a computer science degree i was also a
double major in classical studies which
i don't really use as much but it's cool
to know about ancient greece and stuff
like that
shout out to those electives shout out
to those you know yeah those are
mandatories
if you ever make a any type of thing
with zeus to them you know you know you
know what's up
yeah i mean it's hot right now
odyssey so yeah so after that
i still didn't i had a you know an okay
programmer i guess after you'd go to
school but
i didn't have a lot of game experience
so um
so i went to grab in between i went to
grad school for like game development
yeah but in between i
i um over the summer i did qa for kind
of a um
oh wow more casual studio called
funkotron which made kind of
um slingo which is like slots bingo
games and solitaire games
it was it was a great experience like i
just i was doing qa in the sense of like
finding bugs and giving kind of design
experience feedback when i was playing
through so um and you know those are
like my first game credits so
always salute have a special control
place of my heart yeah absolutely um
so then i went to school in at depaul
for in chicago for a couple years
chinatown
yeah which you know was was cool and
very cold also
yeah that wind i feel like
that wind is serious yeah i i
experienced that one one time and i'm
ready to never experience it ever again
the classic is like leaning into it at
like 45 degrees and then the wind stops
and you're just like oh
like i'm all the way over um but so i
that's where i really started like
making games i i did some like
out of class game making we had like a
group of students that made one over a
summer and then i made some just in my
classes so that's where i really kind of
built out
nice my portfolio which is kind of
for games is such kind of a new field
there isn't like
education isn't really required but you
have to kind of be able to show
that you can you know so i would like i
had these like playable demos and stuff
on my website that i was like see i like
i can do it i got you i got you so would
you say
at the time like it wasn't um it was it
was harder to get in games because there
were the specific games program so
you had to have a yeah yeah the all
these different
skill sets so to speak and then like i
guess my question is as a pro as opposed
to
is it now i'm assuming it was much
harder back then because there were
maybe
programs that would gear directly
towards game development or am i wrong
there there were those things in place
there there weren't that many um degree
programs like i
remember looking at like a few there was
like depaul and
like uh usc and you see
something i don't remember and like full
sail was around back then
right and digipen um yes did you play
but i mean i don't know if it's it's
like definitely easier
to find a game program to go to now
but i don't know if that is translated
to be like it's easier to get it because
it's like now more people
are doing that so yeah absolutely and
there aren't
um like i was just kind of extremely
lucky to get my job like
have an opening at the time that i was
like looking for a job let's get to that
fit yeah so so you lead them right in so
basically you know what led specifically
to the firaxis game opportunity like
obviously
you know a tremendous history the studio
you know the x-com franchise would sit
by a civilization
you know what i'm saying i mean this is
a this is a big deal so
you're getting started like how did you
come across this amazing opportunity and
i'm assuming you're fairly young you
know at the time so
this is a good deal 2023 when i started
24 something like that
i don't know it was 2013. however
[Laughter]
tell us how you wowed them with this
skill i i mean
i think if anyone tells you that there
wasn't like a lot of luck involved in
getting into their
game actually
a trend that you know everyone says that
we have especially devs
almost all of them say my first like
huge hit
into the industry was pure luck so
paint the picture take the pictures so i
was
in my last semester of grad school
so i was so basically you were just make
i was just making
like you have like a capstone project
that you make over kind of the end of
your
so it was like i was working with a
little team and we're making kind of a
game to be
to showcase and be like hey we made a
game
um but uh so
i think i got an email from one of my
professors one of my professors had met
garth deangelis who was kind of the lead
producer of a lot of the x-com games
xcom 2 and yeah i think eu and i'm not
sure
some of the expansions but um so he is a
big deal there
and so they had met at like a gdc or
something game developers conference
so there's all these like six degrees
seven bacon connections
eventually i got email that was like
they're looking they're actually
looking for kind of designer program
like and plus fraxis is a very designer
programmer
um paradigm studio which not everyone is
like a lot of times
designers will just kind of not do any
programming right it's usually separate
that's kind of like a combination skill
set like
usually they're two separate sometimes
you know right and in school and like as
i developed i kind of
wanted to do design so i still was doing
programming because in school you know
you have to do
a lot of stuff but i had started to do
more design stuff like on our kind of
extra summer project i was the lead
designer
and i was a designer on the capstone
game so
um i kind of you know had design student
credits at least
nice so but they you know they had
designer programmers which was something
i could do um so i kind of i got the
email
then um my press like you only sent them
your resume and i was like
give me like one day to like put
together my website
[Laughter]
so i put it because my resume is like
you can look at a demo on my website
um scrambling at the last minute and it
was it was cool i actually had game
credits from my
for my summer thing as well so um but
then it lets you
yeah it was good enough to get a phone
call so i did a phone call with um
jake solomon wait wait wait the
legendary the legend called the phone
yeah you just randomly called me up it
was crazy was him
uh casey o'toole who was like the the
lead uh
engineer on x-com eu and garth arnold
was it might have been great
enemy unknown right enemy announcement i
call it eu i know you're speaking
um but yeah so i know my phone call went
well i guess
yes i mean it was pretty i think
something that
um that people trying to get into take
note of is like
one of the most valuable things you can
bring is being like a new person is just
kind of being
excited to be there you know absolutely
let's be real that website was popping
man they looked at that website i was
like we got to get this dude on
yesterday
i think that website is still the same
so i was like hey i'm a grad student you
know
but yeah i must say they must have been
a press fight i guess
but yeah so i i mean i was super excited
to talk to him obviously i i played xcom
a bit and
sieve and so i was just like
um because chicago has kind of a indie
game culture there are some big studios
around like netherrealm and
yes volition is in champaign so it's
pretty close
um but a lot of people were doing like
indie stuff like i was
um i knew kind of the young horses guys
who did octodad and bug snacks
like they are oh yeah they were like
they were they were a student group at
depaul so they were kind of like mentors
for like
they were like a few years before i got
there so i got i got a shout out bad
coffee from splash damage he goes
designers that can code are the best
designers in my humble and totally not
biased opinion
i totally agree i'm not biased either
it's a little splash damage i see you
you want to get the super chat real
quick song
i think we got a dragon heart and i
don't know if we got anybody no we
didn't miss anybody before that uh we
got dragon heart
with the 20 law stupid chat peace love
life to the panel isle people we're
reaching new heights and i'm saying this
now
though dominance maximus are written
spencer will be a special guest
speaking it into existence y'all y'all
all are forced to be reckoned with
a hashtag mass effect i'm not reading
that part
are you silencing the realm yeah are you
silenced because they know that
you're twenty dollars
taking a page out of my book he just
slips that
i'm surprised cognito didn't sit and
just proactively read it
i miss this i have to praise this man we
would love to have phil spencer on but
yeah we would that that's that's a a
goal it's always a goal for lord for
lord phil maxwell
what is it i forget all the time oh no
come on
too many times too many times
this is the new year yes fraud alert for
me okay
you're right correct obviously say his
name
bill dominus maximus aurelius spencer
when you get the urge to say spencer
just remember you guys say aurelius
is
oh my gosh i have to deal before god
this is the clan this is channel five
back in a day you know saying and he's
clearly pocket watching
wow how much money did this guy's
parents make
jesus pocket pocket-watching lord nora
stop by
watching you absolutely
i warned you i'm a spoiled child
he did open the sentence
so look we got this going on um again
you get the call
you know it's like hey start this this
new position
you know i mean it's pretty amazing
pretty you know tremendous opportunity
so again you were saying you know what
they're looking for this unique skill
set
okay boom program slash designer now
the first project when you get over
there are you jumping straight into
xcom 2. i'm assuming you're jumping to
xcom 2 at this point
or what was the first thing you hit the
ground running on as far as what you're
working on
right yeah so after i you know did find
at the interview and they hired me
which game dev interview was like an
all-day interview like you go
i got flown out which is crazy um but
then it's like you interview different
people all day and it's really stressful
yeah it's intense but i did it so you
know maybe i don't have to do it again
who knows um but yeah so i started on
xcom 2.
it was i got there before enemy within
the expansion
to xcom enemy unknown came out um
so i think a few months before it came
out i think um
but so i started it was like really
early day like a lot of the team was
still kind of
on enemy within they were just kind of
kind of trying to get ahead of like some
new problems for x come to like so i
started
mostly doing programming stuff like i
was helping
um get the procedural map system up and
running
nice um which was like pretty stressful
like
i'd because in school i'd mostly used
unity to learn
and then it was like here's unreal
the programming language was like pretty
similar but
there's all these engine particularities
and stuff that i didn't know like how
you load objects and stuff
which i needed for procedural maps
yeah but we got there um
yeah i got a question because um when we
go to pax we
always you know find out and i i've
noticed that a lot of the indie devs
uses unity and unity uh the toolset has
definitely become more robust
uh as you know years progressed uh the
unreal
uh engine that you were using that was
probably like unreal what three
at that time yeah yeah so yeah because
i'm giving the time period
so it's like
yeah but you already have build up uh
yeah the engine and stuff like that so
it was easier to go in and fix stuff
up uh and i think they did the bridge
from what is it four to five a whole lot
better
it's like a drop-in type of thing anyway
um
my question is when you went to the
unreal
right did you feel that it gave you all
a better flexibility opposed to unity
and i know that
unity is something that you trained on
right and something that you grew up in
but when you got to uh unreal and you
you started to learn it did you find it
was a little bit more robust in its tool
set at that period of time because i
know time has changed already but
i'm just talking about at that period i
don't know it's kind of
apples and oranges a little bit because
um
i mean unity at that time was still it
was really flexible like
you know that was the strength i think
of unreal over unity was that it
for if you wanted to do particular
things it was better at them like if you
wanted to make years of war
like unreal three was really good at
that yeah um
um but unity it was like you know you
could put a script onto any object and
then that would take its behavior so
it's really flexible
i think um the the kind of learning
curve for me was like
i was building off of uh
what they did with enemy unknown and
enemy within so i had to learn this
whole new code base there
okay and like that development was like
you know they made a new thing and it
was like they were really rushed
so a lot of engineers were like we don't
want to do things this way anymore
so like rip all that out and like the
whole
tech behind how like soldiers moved
around and turns visualize the next com
change between
enemy within and x2 wow i didn't know
that wow
we wouldn't know we we play the games
but
you know from the aspect of it yeah by
the time we get ahold of it
the headaches are gone they're done but
they're mostly gone
we forget addict because of that you
know um you know as far as the
the maps being procedural we forget that
right like it's not static stages a lot
of times
but yeah there's nothing and i remember
um
especially and the older one uh at the
enemy within like there was
there was a lot on that one oh yeah yeah
absolutely absolutely
so that so now you the transition to
unreal
what did was it was it a difficult one
for you or just you know
uh just an adjustment in general it
wasn't that bad i think
once you can kind of code in a competent
way like
learning the new syntax like unreal had
its own kind of semi language that
had some weird quirks to it but i mean
you get to use them pretty
pretty fast um so it wasn't too bad i
think it was more like
what is like xcom trying to do so like
my first days there were just like
stepping through all this code and being
like
putting break points and being like
because
the enemy within engine was very weird
again we ripped like the craziest thing
that i remember that i didn't rip this
out because i'm not confident enough
this was like
from the tactical and strategy game like
the base and the
battle map were actually like two
separate games pretty much wow
and like the save data was actually like
loaded on to the drop ship
object and like brought over wow i was
like
what wow i didn't realize eventually
they became kind of one
oh so somebody's smarter than me system
engine in the year made a kind of one
game so pretty much that was their
workaround and you was having to learn
all that at one time
yeah so you know that's a lot
a lot of kind of professional coding is
like that where you'll be like you'll
come into something that's already
pretty big and be like
or like you'll come back to something
you did years later and you'll be like
what idiot did
[Laughter]
i'm the idiot but you had no time or
whatever
you know orion experience so you're
going through that you're on xcom 2.
you know and um also at xcom 2 because i
want to get into what
we're going to get into one choice
because me and attic we affectionately
call war of the chosen the goat that is
the
that is the the the bar the definitive
turn base we got
our game what was it the game of the
year game was in our game of the decade
list
yeah it was it was my top three game of
the uh the
the generation exactly now before we go
there in
um xcom 2 you had a lot of little dlc's
i believe you had like
alien hunters you had shane's gift which
is an amazing story um
point which i really like with that
character um my question specifically
was alien hunters because
at that time i remember playing the game
and added
a test when when an alien hunter dropped
on the map
it was pure fear and i never had to
experience like
every time you go and one of your units
go the alien hunter goes
and that at its time was very
transformative and scary and these
things had tons of health they would
terrorize you at any point on the map
you know what i'm saying so get out
again you know like the worst thing is
when
is when you're already having a bad
match yes he was like oh okay i just got
to kill this dude hopefully i can get
out and then he just shows up out of
nowhere
queen oh bro berserker
it's like and the snake
it's just like especially that i don't
know i feel like i hated the archive
more because i didn't like the homie
missiles because like
the difference between the regular
archive ad and him
yes he could shoot the the pre uh
ones where it shows where they're going
and then you can only move one person
the rest getting
knocked out oh you get knocked down yeah
yeah it was a b it was bs you know yeah
y'all were very that was very he was he
was late game though so at least there's
that oh he was late
has there ever been a time where you've
made or you're making like the war of
the chosen or
or the aliens but they were too broken
and you had a nerf before
exactly oh all the time
like game balance is kind of like this
is a sid meier thing is like you always
either like
double or have numbers so you'll be like
oh it's a little underpowered just like
double that number
and then it's like it's like you double
it's like okay it's a little overpowered
they're like
it's fine because i mean in the
transition before we transfer to the
world chosen because
i remember at that time and i mean i had
confidence in my my turn-based chops i
felt i was you know i
i would overwatch every step and i would
you know i was that guy
you know what i said but that mechanic i
feel fundamentally changed the game
you brought fear to the game it added a
different level of complexity and
to see you do that and then we're gonna
get into ward chosen but
like what the chosen was something else
that that was
like i put it this way i know people who
played xcom 2
and then they played water chosen they
were like this is i can't
it was so unforgiving for some people in
the start
when the chosen came and added what if i
were correct was it
in the beginning before patch alien
hunters and would have chosen
on the back at the same time or no there
might have been a bug like that
so talk about like that in reference to
like i said the difficulty
with adding these kind of you know these
bosses and stuff like that in the game
you know kind of yeah and whoever
decided to let the alien
overlords run after a certain amount of
damage
i i i'm not liking that person if that
was you i apologize
but well that was that was for your own
safety
he's almost dead and i can't heal like
two
yeah well we wanted to i mean
it had a lot of i don't want to say
backlash but some people like bounced
off it because it felt like
we were we were cheating or something
it's against the rules
um the whole idea with them was the kind
of you know how can we do
boss like let's do a take on like boss
enemies
like we had big enemies like the
sectopod and stuff
um but they were just kind of like
they could take a bunch of damage and do
a bunch of damage but they didn't really
have any
special mechanics or anything um so
with exxon being as punishing as it was
um what we tried to do
to make it not as funishing with these
guys that would react because we felt
like yeah it would be scary like
these guys operate kind of fundamentally
differently absolutely um
was most of their abilities didn't
like do that much damage they were
mostly about debuffs and stuff
right and like they actually had ai that
would like make them leave if they
debuffed enough people
like um i i don't know if it was stunned
or knocked down or whatever but
like if they did enough stuff to you
they'd be like all right i'm out of here
but it's still like you had to really
utilize
the kind of dlc weapons and stuff a lot
to
fight them the axe was great and
um anything that could kind of like stun
them or whatever like the bulk cast
that axe was a was a free turret so they
said that he's about to give
up what i like that they did what i
thought was really cool is
after you beat any any alien ruler
you would dawn the suit of the you know
anyone have like special power i
remember having the snake suit that i
beat them and
having those crazy powers and stuff so
that i thought that was really
really cool and then you would use that
to kill the other ones yeah
you know that's it so again you're
working you're working on this stuff as
well during that that phase before
water chosen yeah i mean i worked on
pretty much i worked on all the dlcs
except for
uh the first one which was just
cosmetics um
because that was like while we were
finishing up that was like resistant to
something like that
uh anarchy's children anarchy's children
yes those wild suits the punk suits
that was all jake you know yeah
jake did that because jake's just they
gotta have hot pants
i think i think like fury road like had
just come out
like when we designed or like those
things yeah
like the dlc actually came out way after
free road so
um like it'll still be cool and i think
there's a lot of cool pieces in there
but uh
so for alien hunters i did some stuff
and then i was kind of like
more of a point designer on chen's last
gift
[Music]
like the smart class and i didn't design
the mission fully because we have good
level designers
that do that but i i kind of gave my
i gave like an outline for what i wanted
that mission to be oh dude that was
amazing i got to give you oh i got
slowed down got slowed down
i remember that dlc vividly and it was
it connected
part one and part two this is what i
felt y'all was at y'all best narratively
because you had the engineer was the
older guy
right from part one enemy whatever and
then it was the oh man i forget the
asian chick's name
um yes sorry correct the shen's
yes yep so it was a shed's laugh gift
and it was this cool side mission
to find out you know and then you you
you look i don't explain too much but
for those
they did that with the scientists too
yeah and it was this cool gift that was
left in his memory and it was really
even this i i had to sit about it kind
of saved to my xbox hard drive but um
yeah salute to that that was a great
narrative mission i didn't
know you had a part of that that was a
tremendous
the scientist from the first one was the
one that made the alien hunters mm-hmm
why we don't know we don't know
um yeah also mass effect shout out like
julian
from julian from chancellor's gift was
is morden's voice
is like the admin speaker i know i
always love looking this stuff up here
oh wow you guys shared those voices so
who who's the uh was the was the
commander the guy i like the
of commander you know like that does
that voice honest trailers guy
yeah oh okay dude voice acted t was
strong
very very good chops with it i think
that's what made the game stand out a
lot
is the voice actors voice acting was
tremendous yeah i mean
before the chosen is just like all the
next generation voice actors
yeah let's transition right into it
because again when that came out
just again i was blown away i didn't
even was at the video game we
no we was at the the pc gaming show
where that was first announced we had a
pc gaming show it was first announced
at that time you know x-carb tools i
didn't expect it i didn't expect
it on there at all like you're done with
this oh yeah i remember that moment
and to see these things and and the
chosen again we already thought the
alien hunters were something when you
introduced this mechanic of the chosen
you know coming from the elders and how
powerful they were
and again the terror they caused on the
map
and they came in tremendous story one of
the best dlcs one of the best
i really feel they took it to the next
level like what specifically was your
involvement there with war of the chosen
sure so kind of from xcom 2 like after i
did procedural map stuff i kind of
transitioned to being like the primary
implementer of the strategic layer and
like doing a lot of design stuff there
but moving into where the shows and i
shifted into more of kind of like
generalist like i still implement a lot
of stuff in the strategy layer but
i got to design more tactical stuff okay
i mean i remember specifically i did a
lot of
like we kind of split up the class the
new classes so i did the reaper
oh that's my favorite class that's his
favorite i'm a temple
guy yeah well uh my friend
other designer joe weinoffer did
templars it was funny because we were
doling him up and
joe was just like i'll do templars and i
was like it's like
you just get to do like magic
the templars were pretty broken though
yeah
they could switch with people or just
kill everybody there with the reaper
ability
i just like that anybody got their
proximity somebody they would get
slashed
if you had that ability i used to take
the strongest person on the other side
and i would switch him with my templars
and have all my people gang up on him
yes
absolutely absolutely so you worked on
that while
i forgot about because he added you know
new classes you had advent
improving you got the water chosen but
you also have these other you know
subclasses but
so with the strategy you said you didn't
work too much on the strategy layer
right or
oh i did i was still working a lot like
i implemented a lot of stuff and
so okay go ahead just a quick question
um with the reaper that was all uh one
of the best things uh
that i saw on the reaper was the mines
because because you could
the claymores that's what they were
because you could put two you can find
like a group of people put two claymores
on them and then shoot it and like
literally kill everyone there
what was that something that you
designed
yeah i mean it was still a group effort
like i think how
class design normally works is like
someone will be given it as like
they're like the point designer on it
and will kind of like
make a mock ability tree probably with
extra abilities that like well these
might work as well and then we'll kind
of bring it back to the group and refine
it so it was a group effort
there were a lot of like really broken
stuff that have got taken out
i remember i remember one in particular
with the reaper they
they had one that was like their highest
level ability was like oh their crit
chant
becomes like execution chance or
something wow
but they could just sneak up within like
a few tiles of you because of their
stealth so their chance was like 100
they would just execute you yeah i got
it i'm probably too powerful
i gotta throw some shades our way
because um one thing that was very
unforgiving in my opinion you know even
though i did beat the game it was hard
was like the more the chosen were left
in play in the strategy layer
the stronger you got they got it it
prioritized you
handling one of them soon otherwise they
would gain more abilities and it would
it would just get crazy yeah what's
crazy if you don't kill
all of them and you go to the last
mission they're all on the last mission
[Music]
so were you behind that that evilness
lord lord mark were you
you the source of many players
frustration with this strategy layer
that was
i definitely was was i responsible
i definitely implemented i think i
implemented the chosen's like strategic
abilities
and how they operated on the map so
maybe it wasn't my fault okay um
but i will not forgive the strategy
layer map when you would just see them
the trolls are getting stronger they
chosen to give you
let's deal with them well i think a big
part of what we wanted to do when were
the shows in was
i think with xcom 2 the strategic layer
felt a little cold like so we wanted to
give it more personality and have kind
of more stuff to interact with
so the chosen were they they were
taunting you and you had the resistance
factions that you could go and
recruit from and then you know you could
give resistance orders and you had all
this stuff so
yeah not to mention that uh i i can't
remember if they all can do it but um
i remember the assassin's chick she took
like two of my people at one point
like she would just knock you out and
it's just like take your dude
about that yeah the snatch the abduction
i was also for your safety
it was tremendous but all jokes would
sound like you guys really
the game xcode 2 was already an amazing
game but
you guys added so much to it that we
didn't even think it could even be
more better so again with the strategic
layer with the facts i remember sending
those little what is it i've got the
name of them attic where you would send
a guy out on a special mission
to do stuff cover it up covert ops yeah
and then when you would find them they
would have a pistol
you'd have to evacuate them but what i
liked is they made it
fair in the sense that you could do
things to bring the overall threat level
down
you could do different things to try to
help out the balance but it didn't
what makes xcom great that people
understand as opposed to most turn-based
games
is turn-based games for the most part on
the battlefield they're good at
but with xcom taking to the next level
is that strategy layer that
constant it's the balance between both
of them right and there's the urgency of
you guys might have to do this first you
got to take care of that that's
it's the micro management and it's my
thing because when you
panic yes when that is the worst thing
in the world when you already got your
load out and everybody's good and you're
about to go out
and it goes tommy panics inside the
truck
well and where the
yeah uh so the default panic where like
they could just panic whenever
was taken out like they could only
default panic if they were tired or
worse
i mean but you could also get negative
conditions that would make you panic on
certain things
but if everything was good you wouldn't
panic if like
something bad happened right you know by
default so no but it was cool because
you listen once xcom players get to that
point
like addict where they find out what's
the good stuff the research
you get strong you start giving the
aliens the business back yeah right
you'll be sit there
you'll be like months six or seven
they'll be like oh they're here already
and you go hey that gun researched yet
exactly
let's say you get lucky you defeated
chosen you get one of their weapons down
you start turning the tables on the
aliens you start debo in the aliens
right
but the funny thing without the cool
thing that you guys did
is the tire mechanic because what would
happen is you start specking your four
to six guys that was super op they had
the best weapons
but the tire thing said yo you can't use
him every mission you gotta break now it
forces you to recruit your little
squatties and get other people up
and do stuff like that and i thought
that was a nice balance as well as we
forgot added the um the loss they add
the loss to that as well right yeah the
zombies
yeah the zombies i have zombies yes the
zombies that made my xbox one shake
oh yeah shout out to you taking all the
collections
[Laughter]
it was it was a lot going on with the
cpu during those days
yeah xm2 was already kind of well we
optimized a lot with
the chosen but yeah um yeah
yeah i think the i mean i like the
fatigue mechanic i think
there's like parts of it i don't like i
don't i don't like how it's so
framed in a negative way like but the
results are good
where it's like you kind of passively
get multiple teams that are
actually able to fight yes yeah which
was kind of the goal but it was kind of
like
you know i don't think it feels good as
a player to be like oh my guy's tired
yeah i think you make
people like unintentionally better at
the game in general because
like for instance like when you would
sit with someone through um
the stuff to get uh psychosis or
whatever that's called
you would you would be that person down
so they would have to use a rookie nine
times that's right
but before you know it they're getting
more people killed because they sent two
people to do this
right it's true it's true it definitely
it definitely forced change play style
no yeah the mechanic is a
is a good mechanic it keeps you uh
constantly uh
uh you know instead of uh because what i
don't like is
you have all your your best stuff on one
guy yup
and that and that guy he you know you
already know he's gonna wreck shop
and then let's say for some instance
he's down you got this dude over here
you didn't put anything on him he's not
prepared for the fight
shout out to sanchez or whatever the
random navy was
[Laughter]
because i'm not even going to fraud uh
when i played part two they were telling
me oh yo the expansions is coming the
expansion is coming
and the ripples are coming
um so i was like and i don't know what i
was playing at the time
and i was like man i lost like half my
life to that game yeah i said i can't do
these expansions and they telling me and
they're telling me
hey you know atticus this is why i told
you addict was gonna fanboy like
something crazy
and attic is telling me every day i
can't believe
they did this to me what are you again
about
i was definitely one of those guys that
would rage keep getting away with it
yeah the rage load save guy that
yeah i was that guy girlfriend i i got
so ill at the end of that game
i was killing like whole groups of it's
like i said like when when you get your
hands on the claymores you could kill
like
five or six people and then you get the
the occasional people you can't handle
with the claymores
that's when you just teleport them out
with the templar and let everyone else
kill him
shut up you know shout out to death
stick in the chat a huge xbox conference
he said 99 percent chance to hit and
still miss
she looked at that we did we just roll
the dice all right
they're getting super we actually see it
in your favor on lower difficulties
really yeah so
well it's like we usually i think on the
easiest difficulty
we'll they'll be like an actual behind
the scenes boost sometimes
but usually it's like we do streak
prevention like if you miss like
two 80 plus percent shots in a row the
next one will hit
right but on like the higher
difficulties we don't do that so it's
just
no doubt what you see is what you get
it's probably done in the aliens behalf
then
yeah they gotta help out those aliens
absolutely we gotta trash yourself we
didn't have any super chat we got right
yeah we have a few actually just to do
that there's two uh we have stitch with
the five dollar super chat
this guest needs to come back mass
effect two plus plus switch talk amazing
go get your eyes up tomorrow
we have a slobo backslap with the five
dollars mark
is the transition to unreal engine 5
from unreal engine 4
easier than unreal engine 4 from 3. um
also how much better is unreal compared
to say frostbite
by a little a whole lot i don't have any
experience with frostbite
i mean all i know is kind of what's out
there publicly yes
it seemed like a lot of people had
trouble making stuff in frostbite except
for
dice who was like it was made for her
yeah
but i haven't really done the transition
the five
i mean i don't really know what the
implications are on the dev side like it
seems like there's a lot of
cool like rendering stuff or
optimization stuff
okay um which i don't know i don't know
what that's gonna do to like
the size of the game on the disk if you
don't have to like the
how many polys will just kind of get lod
down automatically so it'll run well but
it's like that object's going to be a
lot of memory a lot
i don't know so i haven't really made
this position so i can't answer that
fully but um i've been using
ue4 for a bit now and i like it and i
think probably most of the kind of
dev experience will be pretty similar i
imagine on five so
it's definitely like i mean it's kind of
weird as a programmer because some a lot
of times
you're doing stuff in blueprint which is
like this visual
scripting thing um which before it was
all
on real script which was more what you
think of when you're like programming
but
i still do like c c plus plus
programming so
okay cool a question question uh to add
on to
uh slow-mo's question just just a very
minor question did they even
roll out uh five fully or
did they like partially roll out five
and then they because i know it's
supposed to be a giant update to
the unreal engine five uh that they will
get
all the extra you know bells and
whistles because i know they're working
on the bridge
to from four to five now right yeah i i
don't know if it's fully rolled out yet
like i haven't
okay we haven't rolled onto it that's
all i really really love but
cool um but yeah i i wouldn't imagine
that it would change kind of
my workflow that much gotcha fair enough
that if we all caught up solved or
yeah okay all right cool so let's
transition into the main event real
quick um
camera squad you know this is a big big
deal
you know kind of like first like i'm
assuming your first really like
leadership position as far as game
design
on a project or the next company this is
your baby so that's the first thing and
then
you know my opinion it was just it was
it was different because yeah just cool
narrative
mechanic-based things make changes
humans and aliens kind of working
together
stuff like that city 31 this whole new
vibe to xcom so like what inspired the
project
you know what i'm saying because it is
different and all these new mechanics
and then
also about the uh the breaching and you
know city unrest and all that stuff and
so the combination what inspired the
project and then also
you know how did it feel to be like yo
this is
this is mine this chimera is me right
what's up yeah yeah
um so the whole project came about
pretty fast
um for a while i've been talking with
jake about potentially leading
something whether it be like another
x2 expansion or like something else
um x2 expansion like
became kind of not a thing because where
the chosen was so big
that it was like i don't even know what
what are we going to put in this game
what could we put in this game um so
and then you know it had been a while
since where the show's in and we did the
um tactical legacy pack yes kind of
i didn't have i like helped set up some
stuff for that but i didn't have a lot
of design involvement with that
right um but it was like we still wanted
to
you know give xcom to people um
so it was like well like the opportunity
came about
for like let's do a small stand-alone
next time thing
and it was um you know it was kind of
like two weeks before the project
started like jake and i were talking
about like
what could it be and then um the idea of
uh what i kind of wanted to do was
kind of smaller faster xcom was kind of
like the major
design yes i guess pillar yes um
and it being a standalone and kind of
like
different lead designer be like well
let's just do
some things differently stuff that we
talked about trying or some things that
just i wanted to do
so with like having
bespoke characters right like yeah
obviously i know people love customizing
characters
yeah i was gonna ask you that yeah i'm
sure when you
first you know decided you're you guys
are gonna go that direction i'm sure you
knew there was going to be push back
there
like a hundred percent um but we had
you know we had tried having more wisp
like the chosen
and like some people from the resistance
factions and where the show's in
and got a lot of positive feedback about
that so i was like well let's
you know i think we wanted to try to
reach kind of the same level of
attachment with soldiers that you could
get from
building your own story and like
customization but do that with
um characterization and their kind of
own uniqueness
um and like yeah we knew yeah like i
said that we knew there'd be some
pushback there like i enjoy because like
you know i make you know a bunch of
anime characters or whatever it's my
squad all the time
um you know but uh
so there was that and then it was you
know with just kind of the nature of the
project
making it kind of like smaller and
faster fit as well because
the project is also going to be that so
um
so yeah it was like i had just a few
conversations with jape and it was like
hey you got a team get going
[Music]
which is not enough time by the way to
really
it's like dozen people what are they
doing and i'm like
i don't know but like like i got i got
to back up because you you glossing over
some things real quick
probably this this is like a big deal
like you
are you know you've been with the
company for how long did you panic no
they're like what was yours
i'm always family that's my secret were
you fatigued
[Laughter]
he's like it's like the hulk what's your
stick he's like i'm always angry
did you drop the grenade and throw the
pin
[Laughter]
whole squad wipes the whole squad
back in the sky it actually would be
funny for uh
a panic if they did something like they
did they used to
yeah before they did the reboot but
michael poll's joyce was evil with that
but jimmy panicked
[Laughter]
and you get shot from the dark somewhere
like yeah remember
you should see that red number one in
the corner you be fearful like you're
like oh my god
oh my god
yeah so i guess like i said the reason
why i got to ask you is two before
because
one you are leading this part like
they're coming to you and they say yo yo
we got confidence you guys run this show
like this is a big deal like this
over there how did that feel i mean it
felt
it felt really good obviously like um
being like it's weird because like being
a good designer and like being a good
lead designer are like very different
things
you know i had obviously delegated a lot
and worked with
people from all the disciplines like
artists and ui people and audio people
so people had a good idea that you know
i worked with people well
but it was like still like being a
manager and stuff is a very different
skill set
yes um and that's kind of i think you
know the side step a little bit it's
like kind of a
bit of a problem in game dev working it
is it like
the path to um promotion is like a lot
of times only up to like a lead position
where it's like
a lot of people are just good at the
thing they do and like don't want to
lead people good point
um but you know i like once i've decided
i want to be designer it's like
you know i wanted to be you know a
creative director at lead designer was
like my end goal
nice i remember talking with our
director
or like my boss of like i could either
like go down towards like a principal
program or route and do more kind of
gameplay programming or be more design
focused
and i was like i want to be more design
focused nice i like programming i don't
you know i don't i'm not in love with it
got you so
uh i don't know if you can answer this
how long did it take you
from beginning to end to develop uh
khmer squad uh
i don't know if i'm allowed to answer
that but i mean it was like you know
it was over a year less than a decade
fan the photo i got to get my best shout
out to bad coffee again
his tactics in the building he said he
loved the xcom
apocalypse vibes in chimera squad was
that intentional or just because of the
city scale setting
um it was mostly just because of the
setting we
i definitely looked at um and talked
with jake about
apocalypse and like we took some
inspiration with like having these kind
of different factions that had different
goals and stuff but
um you know mechanically and stuff we
didn't you know draw too much from
apocalypse
gotcha so i think it's probably mostly
the kind of
future city setting that we were in
which is dope and now
my question with that too is now the
breach mechanic
because this was new to xcon this is
very
i wouldn't say controversial was just
something that i just never
experienced and one you know you're
doing your planning phase you probably
have about three of these kind of setups
per match
like per you know per level and i
thought it was cool because it was
almost like okay
people who are talented or different
members of your team in town could reach
to certain places
these people of mine they're pretty much
swa right it was like
it almost became rainbow six siege yeah
right
it reminded me of seeds and like and and
and splinter cell where you could breach
and you can't you have an idea of like
you come in with an advice all i know is
i always sent the berserker first every
time he said
shout out to the berserker so it's like
for me that was a cool departure but
what was dope is the cinematic nature of
it almost felt
king like some john woo you know boom
or some john wick you know what i'm
saying like you know it was just cool so
like
that was bold that was not in the series
before like
how was your cell or you know did you
come up with that or the team come
together and say okay we're gonna put
this style of thing
in an x-com game cause i never was
number four really you what you did on
that man you popped in there you found
the most bad dude in there and everyone
shot him
take him out yeah the um
i would say that that was mostly me from
like the
at least the original idea like i
definitely didn't implement it the most
because
you know i'm the lead i don't have to do
that
i just tell him what to do
that was the best that was a flex that
was a flex that was
the best you said what am i going to
code
i did code something for commercials
like if i have to code man there's
issues
let's go so very early we kind of had
like
i wanted to do like interiors like
xcom 2 almost like dissuaded you from
wanting to do that because if you like
oh
bust through a door jump through a
window you would break concealment yes
so you like
really we have these great interiors
that like you didn't go in a lot um
so i was like well what if it was mostly
interiors and then
you know the idea of kind of like swat
style stuff came up and it was like oh
you're fighting room to room
and we had early maps that did that and
like
enemies are pretty much just always take
cover by doorways and like have full
cover and you had no way to get around
them
and it was like this isn't fun at all um
so the idea of like a setup phase thing
where it's like you could enter a room
came about pretty early um and then we
had to be like oh you can like breach
the room
and then that what that was like changed
a lot through development like at first
it was like
a fully kind of like frozen synapse like
you plan everything and then they
execute everything
right all the way through that's right
the they you go they go
like that's true continue sorry yeah so
it was but
then it was like we had to like frozen
synapse which was
you have to gives you a lot of
information and you could like rewind
and like
preview turns and stuff it's like and we
didn't really want to do that like it
those games are great but it is very
slow and we wanted this to kind of be
like
blast master processing yeah
we're gonna stick with that yeah i was
like it's gotta be like sonic guys
um i couldn't imagine that it's like
don't come back to me till you have
something to show
someone give me a chili dog
i'm the designer yeah that's what we do
here
continue
[Music]
some coffee hold the sugar that man took
his
[Laughter]
so we had we had breach mode um but
eventually
um another designer um
his name's dakota came up with a kind of
like picking
so we before we had like you pick an
ability to do and then you rush in and
do it
right um so we still kind of had that in
the final project where you could like
pick to do stuff outside the room like
you blow up the wall or you could throw
something in
but then like the extra phase of like
the over the shoulder targeting yeah
um was added and later um and that's
kind of when it started feeling like oh
this is like
this is pretty good because a lot of
game dev is like
this feels terrible for like ninety
percent of the time and then eventually
something happens you're like
that's it we'll we'll go with that um
but so and then like the
i did want it i did envision it as like
this cinematic thing like
i remember thinking about um one of the
modern warfares had kind of a similar
thing where they would breach in rooms
and everything slowed down
i mean we had with in xcom 2 uh when you
would break concealment and kind of do
an ambush
and like if you overwatch a bunch of
people it would kind of like shift the
camera
and slow-mo behind them um so like kind
of elevating that to like
actually have more decisions was kind of
something we did as well where
you know you got to choose who you shot
or you have to choose use different
abilities
um and then after that you would all run
the cover
which we played around with letting you
choose where to go but that
which i think there's like some edge
cases where like
you probably wouldn't want to move where
your guy ended up automatically moving
but that was like
a very small amount of the time and it's
and it slowed things down
so i was like well just try to put them
in the bed
we think there's a lot of like level
designer bugs where it's like i ended up
flanked
after i ran out but there's so much
random stuff we're like we're enemies
spawn so we try to iron as many of those
out but oh you guys did it i apologize
if there's still some
in there you were good man you guys did
a phenomenal job with that
i had to shout out that mechanic i
thought that was cool unique it was a
bold new direction
i loved it you know the alert surprise i
love the uh the city unrest mechanic
and um just in general as an x-com fan
over the years
it felt good to be able to have alien
abilities on your side
and to like especially that viper yes
when the viper was snatched that's good
out of here
you know the viper thing throughout the
game got less and less annoying because
like
who cares you can grab you if you're
talking i'm literally going to shoot you
next turn like
but at the beginning man they ain't
nothing more annoyed that he grabbing
you and put you
on the enemy side of the map yes and
then that dude's dead he's good as that
hey i got i got so much joy in using the
bound because
because it was done to me the snake get
around you would do the ball constrictor
it holds your cap
and you yo your man incapacity you got
to go get the snake
enemy off like i loved having that on my
team
right yeah what i enjoyed the most out
of chimera squad is how
you know in xcom one you uh you were the
people being invaded
xcom 2. you was pretty much doing like
uh you know the
the one in flash attacks where you was
trying to take over as much territory as
possible
and then s comp three you're the one
knocking the doors down on them and not
the other way around
it was it was cool man i gotta shout you
guys on that thought it was amazing um
any other questions will come into
because i got something else before i
move on addict you good with the camera
i'm good i'm good okay cool so look i
gotta ask the elephant in the room now
we gotta put some pressure on them man
ports now the reason why i
gotta stress you guys a little bit
because we we love you guys we guys are
tremendous you know the question always
becomes
with xcom there's always the pc port and
then the console port will sometimes be
almost
a year later so the question is you know
for my console brethren that's in the
chat you know with with chimera and
stuff like that like
you know why so long between the damn
boss
and where do people on console because
these these are powerful consoles lord
mark you got a series
x you got that ps5 i would think people
would
love to play this game on castle
uh what's your thought process on the
port
this guy here i got fresh well you know
if it were up to me
it would go on every i would want i want
everyone to play it obviously
so i'm gonna go on everything jake
please
that had to be promoted to some kind of
like publisher level
i don't know if i'd enjoy that 2k games
let's go
get me up there get me out to san fran
game pass let's do it
[Laughter]
listen we got to shoot our shots now
what we got we don't know yeah
listen you know hopefully uh aaron
greenberg is watching
gamepads now yeah let's get in game pass
i swear
and and i understand we have wasteland
and we have gears uh tactics that's nice
that's nice
but we
to be free because you know in game pass
so we need to have every last piece of
x-com
inside game pass and that way i can
partake
listen shout out to phil dominus maximus
really is spencer
phillip you're listening really need to
have this happen
needs to be more robust as you can see
this young man has worked
very hard to get to the position that
he's in and i don't think his game gets
the proper light and i think it would
have the proper light in game pass
let's have this you can i i think you'll
order something because
that that's my question about the proper
light um
particularly just on rts games yes has
there ever been
kind of internally a conversation about
these games are great we know they're
great
but this why is it after so long they're
still sort of
niche and they they haven't hit
mainstream it was there
ever any conversation internally or what
can we do to these games to make them
more appealing to just mainstream gamers
or yeah or is that like the focus on the
hardcore
there's always a desire to get a bigger
audience because
i mean i think xcom is one of those
games where people who play it love it
and then like
you know people are here it's great but
they don't you know
right yeah exam exam in particular has
got a reputation for just being
difficult so yeah
it's hard to get people to convince
people to be like i don't need that in
my life
[Laughter]
i i've literally convinced people and
they can't get past month three then
they just quit they aren't installed
yeah so i mean one of the chosen did did
some stuff there of like
i think it is it's more forgiving xcom
game for
new people you start with your soldiers
are more capable like they have
abilities they can use every turn and
you know the penalty for getting
randomized
you set them up you know you know those
people about to show up
yeah but i mean so i think it's always a
discussion to get
um you know even with civ which is
bigger than xcom
from a fanbase standpoint is you know
not at the level of like some of the
other major
you know game releases that come out
despite how you know
kind of ubiquitous the civ kind of
franchises i think like the most
probably mainstream civ is civil
revelation or revolution because it's a
lot more
casual that game is mm-hmm yeah yeah
i agree i guess like i said i just i
guess the i don't know if it's the the
studio itself or the publisher in
reference to just the weight because you
know
especially we see in these games i mean
shout out to we had a bad coffee in here
from you know one of the designers of
from splash damage on on gears tactics
and we see gears taxes come out we see a
lot of these games
let's be honest you know you guys are
the og right you guys
are a lot of turn-based guys i like to
kind of pattern their game after that so
you know we see the success of a
wasteland three you know on on stuff and
turn bases kind of
you know uh what is it off emblems what
is it uh from from the switch
um fire emblem yeah three houses like
what
yeah yeah turn basically kind of on the
tactical layer is definitely on the rise
so it's just
i'm just curious if it is if it's a
decision i know you probably can't
answer this but i got it i still have to
ask it just that
is the decision do they think well this
is probably the pc
core base first and let's let's let's
cater to that
and then maybe after we get the money on
the back end or whatever then
we deal with you console players yeah
well
a lot of it comes from just how for
access is in general like we
you know despite what it may seem like
we're not
you know our teams aren't actually like
that big we don't really have the
capacity to
fail enough new ports and houses
there's been efforts um it is a recent
push for us to like
you know work earlier with poor partners
yeah who i got to speak to to get that
[Laughter]
to point me in the right direction do i
need to can we get jake on the side
point me in the direction but that's one
of my favorites
jake's you know trash can in his inbox
um no but i i i agree like
i think you know probably i mean fire
emblem has been popular for a while but
since like enemy unknown um taxis games
or games with tactical layers are
you know really popular and then like
i think now is like this year has been a
crazy year like so many have come out
absolutely you know and that are doing
like different things now like a lot
for a while i think it was like people
would just kind of
be like xcom yeah do that but
change this or do this but now it's like
your tactics is not really like
you know does not function like xcom
really when you control an attachment
his tactics more about aggression that
they want you to get up close and
personal
like like xcom can be like that but for
the most part they do kind of want you
to play defensive to a point
and then go on the offensive like like
gears tax is like i want you that
chainsaw in his gut
and i want you killing that one with the
chainsaw next i i know
uh it uh reached a different audience
when i saw
uh mario rabbids that's what all right
yeah yeah yeah
i think i was going to ask you yeah
literally
said that in the chat he said even mario
rabbids coded by italians like me
i think we all owe for axis and the
noxcon series
in fact we're living in a new golden age
for the genre continue because
i i thought that was a bold move on
their part as far as uh
you know this their strategy uh genre
goes because uh to take their
their ip and to make sure that you know
uh it's in that light you know with
ubisoft guys
and the game actually come off really
well
and it was well received i think that
also green lighted a lot of
other uh you know strategy games
absolutely and tacticals because it's
one game that i'm looking for
uh in particular it's called thunder and
uh
it's you know indie game and i just
showed it uh i think a couple of months
ago but
that game looks like you know they're
going to push the genre forward and
all i'm saying is you know for us to all
really partake for us to
really you know get our teeth into it
yeah yeah you know you you must remove
the barrier of pain
and put this into a format or a system
uh a streaming system or uh downloading
are you
implying the sir gamepad want i want to
point out mark
okay let's say that they're like you
know what king
i agree let's hit up playstation now and
put this
on here all right
wait a second i i i i owner of
playstation plus
mm-hmm i got my little two-year uh thing
so playstation now and playstation plus
youtube
there you go i don't know what i would
say
is you know for the for the
20 million game passes
you know gamepad subscribers that really
need to see your hard work in your team
oh my god no i i honestly believe that
this [ __ ]
and it has to be on the splash page i
would love to see coming soon
or uh just released you know
xcom and then all the dlc
you understand
um when you first saw mario rabbits what
was your first like initial thought
because clearly
that was in some way you know inspired
by xcom
yeah but it's it is a completely
different game i think it is one of the
only
xcom i call them xbox clones xcom clones
but
that's the only one i dropped i never
beat mario rabbits i don't know why
there was just something about it
uh that i was not feeling uh i got like
about halfway through the game but i was
like this isn't for me and i just
dropped it
what was your initial thought when you
saw that type of game
well it was funny because that actually
got announced the same like at the same
time as wore the chosen like the same
thing
right so we were like oh
because because like jake was there and
he was so easily getting questions about
mario and rapids and he was like all
right
i remember i remember that interview
because i think someone asked him
he's like what do you feel about that
he's like well he's like
they should have asked me or something
yeah he did say that yes yes yes yes
i remember that what's cool about being
in
the tactical space is like there's not i
mean there
there's obviously competition like you
want to do well but it's like there
isn't really
rivalries like i want all the title
games to do well because
it is in kind of the space of like being
a bit of a niche genre
so like the success of any game kind of
like brings up bring attention to the
entire list yeah yeah and plus you know
because of you know
the the project that you and your team's
been working on and everyone over there
games like mutant year zero was able to
really capitalize games like
you know there's games like gears
tactics was able to capitalize and you
know
uh you know mario rabbits and because
they're introduced to newer crowds like
especially mario rabbits where you know
a lot of people are willing to try it
because mario's in it
now when you know kermeyer squad comes
out they're willing to try that out
because
you know they gave mario rabbits a try
because they had mario on it
yeah it's like mario rabbids except
mario dies
i mean you could you could always name
him mario
let's get to super chat today we move
forward oh so i'm gonna get that
uh first off we got welcome to the realm
lord
and then after that we have lord blaze
4k with the five dollar super chat
game pass dot dot lo bring it to the
gods
you know um just just just for blaze i
do
know that y'all need games over there
oh my god because y'all actually are
playing nothing right now
oh my god and we're having fun but i
have to say this blaze
honestly nobody wants to go to that
barren wasteland oh my
service i mean the game pass is popping
this
is the real club is the 40 40 club if
you want everybody to go to the bodega
down the block
oh my booby going we're not trying to do
this
time from playstation oh
i don't know
if you get the success of one game helps
all the others if a game does good and
brings more fans of the genre it's good
for everyone
and healthy for the genre survival facts
big facts you order something so look
gotta move on cause we definitely went a
little late
and i gotta get uh respect lord mark's
time he's been pushing it yes
um so look what we gotta do is
just one last question on on the series
and then we'll move on um
as far as you know the elephant in the
room
and we we know at some point
that x-carve 3 has to be hopefully in
development
and from the timeline i think you
explained it before i believe in the
polygon article
as far as canon right so we've got what
is it
enemy unknown then it's that book was it
resurrection
xcom xcom2 war of the chosen and chimera
is that correct from a
cannon standpoint so the
the timeline that chimera squad exists
in is you
lose actually enemy unknown pretty early
right
and then x-com 2 happens and you win
and then you're in this world uh
with aliens and humans yes and city x
advent hybrid
right living together okay okay so
chimera squad is
canon on the record we can say that well
we can't we're going to
trouble as far as i know oh god didn't
get it
okay already i don't know all right no
doubt so we got
he missed the meeting
it's been a long winter break i don't
know what happened so the question i
know you probably can't answer but i
have to ask
is one how far are we
possibly from potential next entry into
the series xcom 3
right which i know you're going to dance
with but i gotta ask
and as far as chimera squad being
such an evolution to this series does
that
do these mechanics kind of now influence
the the direction of the franchise
moving forward
or is that just kind of like a one-off
we're trying some things
this doesn't necessarily mean that's
going to be an x-com three because that
you know
the fans of the series do are curious
about that i just want to know if you if
you could answer
anything all right i'll answer the
second part first i figured you would
continue um and it helps i'm out of time
so with any really with any game we make
um we're always looking for
what fans respond to what they like so
commercial is not an exception we
we obviously tried some stuff that was
more out there i think
um you know there's potentially like a
lot of the kind of stuff we do
we did there you know potentially
wouldn't be appropriate for a sequel
like i would have made the same
decisions if i knew i was making a
sequel
right um but it's like there might be
elements of things that we like that we
could bring over
um you know i don't know i can't really
get any specifics but it's like we're
always looking for feedback
and like um what was the best feedback
you got from camara
uh squad best feedback yeah like in all
the new features that was implied into
camaraderie school
was like very positively like like for
instance like breach to people like
breach to the majority of the community
like breach
i think most people like breach i think
i think it kind of overstays his welcome
a little bit like
you have to do it so much right um but i
i
i think one of the more surprising
things to me was like how
kind of universally popular having
aliens on your squad ones yeah there was
some grumbling about it early but then
like
pretty much everyone liked it which was
like that was one of the things was like
i don't know
people are going to like that but then
everyone is kind of like
how you guys were you're like it was
awesome i got to use like
a viper now you know um
so that that was yeah that was like
thank god that was a big part of the
whole story you guys did good you guys
did good
so i again i don't know we got to try
carefully because we can't get you in
trouble but we
well i mean the only thing i'll say
about the first part of the question is
it's like it's not like it's not like
i'm doing nothing at work
i didn't even think he was gonna go
there who knows what we're working on
who knows what could happen with a three
audience but
he's continually to work on things so
that puts me in a positive space that
potentially things could be happening
yes with that amazing experience you can
say but yeah
you never know you know microsoft
you know he could be undead because the
film might be live
king is on his best behavior right now
he made it professionally he's actually
going for a party right no
no no we're not gonna do that to lord
noah we're not getting that many
i really liked his his grind um and he
said he was uh he was 23
in 2013 and i thought he was 23 now yeah
right so i'm like
man he's he and he's a lead so um
trust me i'm listening to all your
knowledge and and you
you you're growing from this space to
that space
so it's it's it's really intriguing to
listen to everything that you're going
through
and how you're controlling and handling
i mean somebody give me a chili dog was
it was amazing so yeah and and um
honestly
no i i just really want people to uh
really grasp uh this genre more yeah i
don't think that it's in uh
in in the light that it needs to be
because when you get to these turn-based
uh strategy
type games these games are so much fun
especially when it's done right and he's
telling you all the stuff that goes into
it so i don't want to take away from
your time
by me talking and running my mouth you
know so i just want to just hear you
talk more
absolute salute man i mean tremendous
tremendous history
everything's going to super chat i'll
wrap up with them um
yeah we have the living flame with two
dollars super chat there's no sunday
without the lords being messed up of
course we got to be messing with yeah
i had to be messy at the end i'm sorry
sorry
there we have uh michael skew junior two
dollars absolutely y'all football is lit
salutes a little skills thanks for
joining around brother
okay and then we have the insipid ghosts
xbox expansion pass two dollars
salute my friends happy new year
likewise to you sir tremendous podcast
the xbox expansion podcast salute
it's epic ghost button yeah man like
again salute lord order just tremendous
history
amazing story so proud of what you guys
are doing at firaxis tremendous team you
guys
are iconic you know you guys push the
genre forward the things that you do in
turn based
i always look forward to every x-carve
game that comes out but before you go
we gotta ask that top five question that
we ask
all the lords in the realm are you ready
i need lord mark notice
top five crack at night he ready top
five
video games or franchises of
all time this is your personal life they
don't have to be in
any order just these are the impactful
ones for you
uh well top one
you know go out to my super smash
brothers melee
um hashtag free melee free bailey salute
salute i mean it's the only
you know 20 year old game that i play
regularly
[Music]
official let's go that's the one he
travels with
get back on i would i would get
demolished at an actual tournament but
i can all cancel and wait for that so we
got that we got that smash
let's go um i think mass effect is
definitely up there for me
you could say the correct mass effect
you have just now re-sparked this this
night
i might clip this song in there he's
going to clip listen
to every after every podcast
and that's the thing because he has
admin power
we put it on twitter and we like promote
the podcast with that clip
20 bucks say that part
2 is going to be the clip and you know
how i know that lord mark
because every time someone says that
phoenix so many nuggets
all right so that's true and not because
i said that it won't be in there
i love all of them i actually wrote
bioware a letter after three because i
got so much backlash that i was like
hey i really love the game mm-hmm you
know you guys did a great job don't
listen
that's what's up that's what's up so we
got those two number three
oh man i really should have thought
about this beforehand there's so many
so good uh i mean i
i guess i'll just say final fantasy in
general like i love
okay i don't love every final fantasy
game which
one oh no here we go
fantasy i'm not going to cop out and say
tactics even i love tactics oh tactus is
an amazing one too okay yeah that's not
that's not the ones you can't say that
one wow
what the hell is this
[Applause]
if you want to guess look at my blonde
kind of emo hair
thank you listen this is the thing but
he said seven first round
listen i'm gonna tell you right now
people just really don't get that part
that seven is the goat period
that's all he has to say zelda yeah but
seven is not the goat because it's the
best
no i'm just saying that seven is the
goal for the for what it did
exactly and i'll never take that away
from it never
so regardless to where she's
like he did it so it's beautiful yeah so
we got that
i just have to punch you in with the
base again oh my god
the disrespect the lord's water are
legal
i don't hate the people
you can't help the people with that
reminder that's
just what it is all right so you got
that we got that we have the smash
we have the mass effect 2 which is we
got the final fantasy 7
and then what was the one we missed was
what i missed in the middle damn it
oh i had to melee first and then mass
effect and then we're only at three
yeah we only have three oh we don't have
three okay so we got two balls
um i think i haven't i don't play it a
ton anymore but i
i grew up you know kind of middle school
playing a bunch of halo so i'd have to
put that up there
particularly i played so much halo 2
online
that it was like probably unhealthy
xbox live gamer tag you know
it was a revolution i'm playing on like
dsl or whatever i was playing
and have no fear mark there's no inside
joke with halo
you think two's gone
is kind of like a game that like did a
similar
thing yeah so it was like a side game
and like a big
franchise absolutely good inspiration
there absolutely and final one
oh man i'm probably gonna miss some like
crazy
um personally i mean i feel like
just based on the thousands of hours i
play i have to say overwatch
like i love overwatch which is good
because it like doesn't have kind of
like a story
it doesn't have it's got yeah
but i mean i have a lot of stories
playing with friends like i usually play
with a big group
so favorite character character oh
i mean i become like even more basic i'm
just like my boy genji
i love you [ __ ]
i love playing winston but he's like
super bad right now so i don't get to
play him yeah he needs a ball
salute man this top five oh the last one
um
console one console of all time we
already know that answer a lot more than
that
oh man one console all time yeah what
impact did you know
i want to be like a hipster be like just
dreamcast if it's like 13 games
a lot of people say dreamcast too yeah
you get a lot of people that say
dreamcast
they're wrong but they say dreamcast
i feel like i would actually go with
gamecube because of
melee and like there's a lot of gamecube
games i love like
i love playing custom robo um wind waker
is my favorite zelda yeah
um oh wind waker that that's the first
one
oh yeah that's a good zoda anything but
you know firewood sword
he just mocked it clearly he didn't no
no i understand
i understand it's like like sovereign
said it's not for everyone
look fred lord what made you make this
history an
absolute pleasure to have you in the
round we rocked way longer back than we
could kept you from
but um salute to you man where can the
fine people find you what do you have
going on sir uh well i mean
really the only real way to interact
with me is on twitter
i think m underscore nada nice uh i'll
put it in the comments
yeah um but yeah my my dms are open you
can
you can add me if you want um as long as
you're respectful otherwise you get that
fat block exactly
i'm sure i'm sure all your fans will be
fine but i
yeah i mean and then you know i'll be
when we start getting around announcing
stuff we'll probably be more active on
there we'll be looking for you to return
when you start announcing
hopefully hopefully um but yeah i really
appreciate you guys inviting me on it
was really fun i'm glad that
i really appreciate the kind of you
trying to bring devs forward and
you know get people to realize what goes
into making games because
like we're talking about before the
podcast started it's every game is like
a miracle that it even comes out
actually i do have one question that we
kind of ask all the uh
the devs that come on what is the most
thing that you see on twitter
that is like what's what the most
misunderstood
thing about about you know developing
because you got a lot of you know
you know armed developers especially on
twitter that think they know exactly
what goes into making
a game and they know the ins and out and
they say stuff like that can't be that
hard
yeah i mean there's a lot of that
generally is like oh why can't they just
change this one of the things
with game design in general that i think
people don't understand and even
kind of when you're learning about game
design isn't clear is like
how much of it is about finding
compromises that still fit your vision
for the experience you want
but also like can be done in the amount
of time and money that you have
right like a lot of game design
education and stuff is like
you're this kind of like lead with like
no restrictions on you
and it's like you can iterate as much as
you want and like figure out
you know do exactly what you want but
it's like when you're developing an ip
and you have time restrictions it's like
you had to meet expectations of
you know what do fans expect from the ip
what does the publisher want from it
and then also like you know is this kind
of thing the thing that we have time to
do or like
this is going to take a lot of time is
it worth it or do we need to invest
these people's time somewhere else so
but like a lot of probably some of your
favorite parts
of games are born out of these crazy
like we got to make this work like what
can we do and then it's like
someone's like oh i love that part and
you're like i made that because like we
were out of time
total shortcut i guess it's funny when
you
you
hear the stories and and hear how things
come together and sometimes things are
so a last minute or 11th hour
and then it makes it in and it ends up
becoming this amazing mechanic and like
you said you're like oh
you know we barely yeah playing from the
start
exactly yeah we definitely have like a
saying like we don't like using the term
like developers being lazy
because you you you oh yeah yeah because
people don't understand what's going on
behind closed doors and i think it's
like mad disrespectful just to claim
something's lazy
yeah and use it you literally have zero
knowledge knowledge of it
all they suppose all they got to do is i
don't know why they care
you know that kind of stuff yeah
everyone all my co-workers and stuff are
like
some of the most hardworking and like
creative people that i've like ever met
so
absolutely um and i i'm sure it's like
that
at pretty much every studio like
absolutely game industry jobs are like
lower paying than like other software
engineer jobs so it's like the people
that are here really
love it and like you know as a lead like
people gave me like
people who aren't designers give me
feedback about stuff all the time just
because they care
about how the game plays oh that's
amazing man you call them lazy then you
know
that's instant block for me as well one
last question for mark from the chat
um we have uh rd with the two dollar
super chat mark's opinion on game pass
good or bad for david i think it's kind
of like
it's still up in the air like i i love
that like
with anything like this i think it
depends on the studio like it's great
for
like a i'd love that it gets like
potentially a bunch of people that
wouldn't play a game to look at it
you know there's a lot of okay like i
remember rocket league back it was free
on
players and it was like that was super
good for them like
they had this huge player base for their
multiplayer game immediately
um and that led to more sales and stuff
on on steam and stuff like that
um like i've i don't think there's
really we don't have
the data on how if like i don't have any
personal experience within it but right
um but i mean i i think in general i'm
in favor of
you know i want games i make to get into
people's hands nice
you know as much as aaron
aaron i mean uh listen basically what he
just said and he can't say it because
you understand
his situation aaron listen man let's get
his game inside game pass let him let's
show him the mate the metrics and drop
the bag
off let him see the bag first hit him
with the bag i think mark would like the
bag
yeah the developers get paid then show
him
exactly the metrics on how it reaches
20 million people and also show him
how all the dlc which is free inside
game pass
it's funded through microsoft's uh
infomercial i mean i think i think it's
absolutely
time for this game to be inside
the legend of the xcom franchise as well
as water chosen man an absolute
pleasure and honor you guys again set
the gold standard when it comes to turn
based
tactical games can't wait to see what
you guys are working on next man
absolute pleasure and hope to have you
back in the realm in the future man
enjoy your sunday bro this was an
absolute pleasure
yes well yeah thanks for having me you
know my dm's are still open
i'm happy to come back you know it's a
lot of fun nice we would love to have
you back brother
enjoy the rest of your sunday all right
you too brother have a good one thank
you
we caught up with supers i believe we
are give me one second
yeah that that was a very good first
guest of the year
yeah um and i know it meant a lot for
you guys
i mean my my education with uh
xcom uh is earlier on and you know with
xcom 2 as far as you know
um not getting to the dlc that you guys
got a chance to touch
yeah i mean but really made a highlight
yeah
like i can honestly say that like when
they make
it's exactly like he said like when they
made um
war the chosen like they're like what
else could we possibly do because like
like we're the chosen i'm still myself
like i don't know what else i could do
to top that
yeah like that to me was one of the
ghosts yeah look overall put up the hard
side he's in the chat
absolute brother i mean honestly for him
to be as young as he is
and to have experience so listen man
he's the lead right now
you and that's more greatness to come so
he's learning for whatever things that
came before him
so when y'all talked about part three
and i'm pretty sure that they're working
on stuff and have stuff draft up or
maybe they have a totally different
like i heard it was i heard it was
something new
yeah a new ip in a whole new direction
and stuff like that and taking all that
information that they do have
yeah man yeah somebody get this man a
chili dog
i mean again tremendous guests trying to
get as much as you guys questions as
possible
you know obviously i was gonna say y'all
know we went super long i want to do a
condense if y'all don't mind
yeah let's do that so let's get into
that but before we do that we got a poll
i believe
last week's okay last week 12 results in
the people spoken to the question
which negatively initial negatively
received iep deserves a chance at
redemption by the gaming community
the winner of the four-way ilp poll at
48
was cyberpunk 2077
coming in at second place at 32 percent
was i don't care craig the gun gonna
silence the haters
in 2021 in third place at 12
was anthem 2.0 and in last place only
seven percent of the vote was
next mass effect group shout out to all
the lords who participated
yeah the people are smoking cyberpunk is
it is what it is so we're going to get
into this topic
that game came out yo
i heard it didn't come out yet i heard
it came
out for those dudes that was playing
them old systems oh
my god yeah when it shows up let me know
let's let you know
it's a kick this is your topic you'll be
the favorite real quick let me get it
yes please
all right cool so look man ps4's uh
right now it looks like japanese outlet
uh
game watch reporting that sony's gonna
be discontinuing all
but one ps4 model why is king dancing
in japan only the 500 gig slims will
remain in production
as uh sony japan pivots uh his attention
to ps5 that means all other models
including the ps4 pro have been
discontinued with no
new stock on the way and it just said uh
yeah they're just talking about the the
console sort of stuff like that but
yeah they said that another according to
another twitter user the japanese
retailer also posted that five ps5
models aren't being
stopped due to the manufacturer ending
production so this is the word lord king
you're
you're feeling that you have to bring
this to the realm na na na na
[Music]
[Laughter]
now this is yo this only bodes well for
playstation owners
all right let's cut production on that
whack old system and let's
move forward let's because we believe in
generations
right so we believe in the generation of
the playstation 5
and going forward uh we will only you
know stock the
500 gig joint in the bushes listen
you know for little team timmy that
needs a playstation 4 to play
all the games that is cross-gen that
which is every game they have coming
um but the playstation 5 is selling at a
rate that has forced them
to just abandon the playstation 4 and i
think that is the proper move going
forward let's stop focusing on the old
stuff
let's focus on the new stuff and this
only means
great stuff as far as getting games to
just
run on the playstation 5. because it
will be a conflict of interest in my
opinion
if they're still producing the
playstation 4 that means there's still
new playstation 4 owners
and you don't want somebody to just
purchase a playstation 4
and you know they're not making games
for it they say just you know play the
old library
so yeah stop production on it so their
way that way you don't have that person
that just went out and purchased it
and it can be just like you know entry
console to the playstation ecosystem
with the playstation
uh for uh 500 gig and let them start
focusing on getting more playstation
fives out there because i still have a
couple of friends of mine who don't have
one who do
want one right and um get those uh
consoles to everybody's hands and then
change the attention towards this new
generation and game design and stuff
like that so i just
saw this up there i know microsoft has
done the same so i'm keeping the same
energy on both sides of the fence
when they uh stop production on xbox one
x
and you know they only i think they're
only doing like the digital only one
right now
uh they they drop production on on the
other
consoles i believe so i think this is
the proper thing going forward for both
uh console manufacturers so lord adam
your thoughts ps4 is discontinued
i don't care i'm not buying another ps4
so let that get discontinued
it don't matter to me if you ain't
bought a ps4 by now
then i don't know what to tell you man
like you you just i don't know i don't
have to acknowledge you for it let's
just move on let's act like this never
happened
solve what do you think i mean they're
gonna keep selling you that slim
eventually that's going to be a buck to
a but to 200
and they're going to keep telling you
that um it makes sense to kill the pro
because the pro at this point
never really got a price drop so it's
the same price as the old digital ps5
right yep
you know why not just focus on ramping
up that ps5 development
and get ps5s in people's hands and not
the pro um
so it doesn't make any sense for them
and if and since the price didn't go
down you could assume
that it would it still cost them you
know whatever it's been costing them to
make that because there'd be no reason
not to drop the price right
um same thing with the with the one x
that that's why
the one extra become the base xbox
because it's still too expensive to
manufacture and when you have a 300
system in the series s
it doesn't make any sense completely so
yeah uh you know it makes sense and
the other ps4s that are being you know
those are like you know special editions
and stuff like that that
had limited runs anyway so
it is interesting to see that it's so
fast
right because they didn't stop making
ps3s until well into the ps4
generation so it is interesting but
again i i guess it speaks to the
popularity of the playstation nobody can
find
it and they feel they can make up that
difference by just cutting out these
other consoles that
you know that yes they could make money
on but it it would require too much and
it would take away from ps5 production
so yep
good on them i'm with you you guys said
it pretty much everything i'm saying um
common sense um just like the xbox one x
you know that was
discontinued remember there was this
whole oh it's going to be confusing when
the series x comes
you don't remember when jw hit me oh
who's the most powerful now not y'all
[Laughter]
not y'all at the end of the day it's
just you know they discontinued that i
believe on
july 2020 and um they got rid of
those and that's how you slowly
transition everybody over to the to the
new job you know so
i'm i'm cool with that you consolidate
you got now
ps4 slim ps5 digital ps5 regular
you give them less options yeah they're
naturally just going to
gravitate towards a new thing yeah
that's right three-skew approach
you know not gonna confuse people and
consolidate transition that's it let's
get the super chat before we move on to
that
that's what they were saying like people
were so confused i i don't think so
no doubt uh we got rubber knob with the
phone
i love yo he added me on xbox shout out
to my man bro
cause i'm gonna introduce him to my
friends
morning lords green thumbs be glowing
spent the weekend planting bushes even
some spiky ones
all ready for 20 20 somebody gonna get
cut into the money gonna get thrown this
is just
then we got the wise old gamer with the
five dollar super chat it's time for my
meds and god knows how i'll be
afterwards i wanted to stop by and show
some love
now i gotta go get ready for my
spongebob you get that spongebob yeah
everybody show some love to the wise old
gamer
uh he recently had to get back into the
hospital um but thankfully
he has his own room he has his consoles
so he will be entertained in addition to
games with fun faster
we have the living flame for the 2010 i
know where this is going get him king
hashtag
to do a little combination right so yeah
really doing me so you got
next level and then i'll set up um next
basically nintendo's purchase and i'll
set up the uh yeah
the switch pro yeah so uh nintendo went
out and purchased next level games uh
next couple games uh
basically been a second party developer
for them for
the longest time so it was kind of
strange to see them purchase them
because
they just they usually have those
relationships that stick they have no
need to purchase
uh these companies right but i i kind of
feel like with the
consolidation of the games industry
coming with the big purchase that
microsoft made
it has everybody a little bit on their
toes like let me gobble up
as much as i can because i may not have
access to these
uh to these companies in a couple of
years especially
if you know obviously microsoft is going
to continue to grow game pass
so they want more stuff and everybody
has a price right everybody can be
purchased
and and eventually playstation has to
start pivoting towards that as well
so they're going to be looking at making
purchases obviously not as big as that a
max purchase but
right you know they they could
potentially
yeah yeah they could potentially take
off other take developers off the table
so
i think it's a smart move on nintendo's
part um the difference between nintendo
and
other companies is that they don't take
they don't buy developers
to because of what the developer brings
to them they buy the developer so they
can make nintendo
games right right and so this is ideal
for them because
this company has made games in the past
they made nfl hits in the past
they made uh the captain america game
for xbox 360 if anybody remembers that
um but for the most part they're most of
their success has come
with nintendo ips with strikers and
obviously louise mansion
so i think it's a great move they i
think they needed to do it and it's
it's weird because nintendo doesn't come
off as the company that
acknowledges and realizes this stuff is
coming right sometimes the wave comes
and they're like oh what happened
um so it's it's kind of it's kind of
good that they're preemptive about this
and they know they gotta
they gotta kind of lock up some
developers okay so that's that's the
first part with the next level for me it
was just the um
switch pro obviously new rumors once
again
once again there's another you know hot
leak you know apparently some guys i
can't pronounce his name scary's m
but he's like some reverse hacker who's
supposedly you know reputable so anyway
look
code name uh alua okay au la
la la la yeah so it's been data mined
it's supposed to have 4k support
oled screen potentially a new docker for
added power
and um again it said that this real time
4k this uh the soc chip is on
on the on the clock it says current
switch models will not be able to take
advantage of this new dock that will
have more power
and then they said that expected
speculation is there will be games
optimized for the new revision of the
switch
just as there was with the ds and the um
ps4 pro
and uh yeah so pretty much like i said
this guy's supposed to be known in this
you know hacker reverse hacker um
engineering scene now his tweets have
been since taken down i don't know if
that means
that he got got to cease to desist or
someone said so if something's going on
you know so again let's start with
again the uh next level games and
thoughts on switch pro
at it oh you guys thought i fell back
he's like i'm about to start eating i'm
about to go to pizza you see how you
talk to the size
of these topics first and then did the
interview like i i'm just i'm just
generally mad tired like look
i think that they should have a system
that's stronger
and the only reason i feel like that
should be done is it's not for
first party stuff is for third-party
stuff you know you got your handheld one
uh and then i think you should they
shouldn't be a hybrid one there should
be a handheld one
that and then there should be a console
one that plays third-party games like
call of duty et cetera et cetera
but you can only play those third-party
titles on that
hardware you can't play it on the head
yeah doing that
well no but see the thing is like you're
not going to get these games anyway
so it's just like like so if you
you you make this type of you know
split the base it's not that you
splitting the base
well you're giving the option you're
giving the option to play games they
wouldn't have been able to play anyway
there's a reason cyberpunk's not on
there because the console physically
can't do it right that's not true so
because i just saw the atari vcs
i mean and it's pretty much playing
cyberpunk how cyberpunk is playing on
everybody's console
horribly but all i'm saying is you know
people buy nintendo games mainly for
their first party
for the pokemon for the luigi's mansion
because they just bought that company
and all i'm saying is like certain games
they run bad if they're third party i
mean look at look at the magicary that
that uh they had to do to get diablo now
diablo
doom running on the switch like all i
feel like is
you know if if you want that third party
support but you don't want to buy a pc
you don't want to buy the other consoles
it would be nice to have
a machine that's at your house that is a
switch it still plays the switch games
but it can also play those third-party
support that you wouldn't have got
regardless right
what about the managers what about the
when they've been experimenting with the
cloud stuff with control
so let's just say they give the old
switch guys the cloud option like you
know
like you guys are saying with halo
infinite right you guys want halo
infinite
to come next year are you telling me
what's going to happen
you know your knees are coming to us
resistance is futile for your knees
he lost his knees
oh you know what about that option you
know with the switch
you know the old switch you know maybe
getting the the cloud version and maybe
the switch pro you know being able to do
what they do
i think that when it comes to a
situation like that
if they can make it work cool make it
work but at the end of the day
the switch is a portable machine anyway
so like are we going to be able to
stream stuff
without your wi-fi at home like are we
going to be able to do it over
you know a mobile carrier like a hot
spot like i don't know
like maybe maybe when 5g
is like a common thing stuff like that
that's things that people don't really
take it might be a companion concept
we are seeing a world
that is building up for 5g right
for like these streaming apps et cetera
et cetera is putting 2g in a box
but when i say what i'm saying
is nintendo i think that's their
that's their answer to third party it's
like look we can't arm
we don't care about our third party but
we do understand that some people do
like you got to think about their
chipset their chipset is in video right
and it's still a tegra one like that
right but
the new chip is won't be integral one no
that's what they're saying it's just up
clocked that's what they're saying oh
throw this
he's not about it no more he's out of
fight
the added power the added power is
supposed to be in the new dock
right you will get a higher clock and on
the on the
on the portable machine so old stuff
will run a little faster
i've heard that you can't use it in a
new dock that's one of the rumors
they say one of the rumors is that it
can't be yeah it can be it has to be
this new console
because i'm gonna tell you right now if
you're doing integral one you're just
being defiant and ignorant
right now you're just at the ignorant
stage and you just don't want you
want to be crushed you you think you
know what happens i cannot stand these
dudes that think they can't get broken
like you really think because you've
been on this 26 28 month roll
that it just can't stop remember y'all
used to be the hot mess
feeling switch coming in everyone
no listen they can rock as much as they
want to rock that is cool you can really
rock on any block i don't care
but i tell you this you play you put
that tegra one in there you think you're
going
to say that call of duty nah but they
don't even know
they won the launch of new console yeah
i don't care what they're doing in
tommy's house
i don't that's the billion i want them
to do something in my house i purchased
them
so i want them to get busy in my house
and right now they have not been getting
busy
but whatever they doing every month
selling it to everybody across the globe
that's their business
i say this if you put tegra one in that
box mark my word you're looking for
death
you will have marked yourself for them
because listen this xbox series x and
this playstation 5
is not playing and all those win those
games
the okay take advantage of these
consoles
and nintendo's sitting there on their
hands playing luigi mansion 4.
it's not going to work out i think
that's why it hasn't worked this whole
generation
for them no everyone they've literally
won like cyberpunk
came out this came out since they came
out all the dope soda exclusives came
out
they have survived like three or four
npd's since
this time you know you know what's cr
kind of crazy
they have been producing a tig which one
chip
at such a rate that they getting those
little things out the door
so it's available you ran inside the
store you was like yo let me get that
playstation file let me get that series
x let me get an
s let me get a digital five what's up
thing like nah bruh
we ain't got that we got that switch
though they don't even have to switch
that's what you sold out everyone too
nah they got those i can't
don't don't try to act like them those
things they did them things is there
they're selling to somebody they are in
the store i see them in the store when i
go in there it's never been a day
except for when they've been in the
king's world
you know i'm gonna go to walmart
and i'm not gonna take a picture they're
just not stocking them over here
i'm going to go to walmart and i i'm
going to
tweet on twitter and say king there's
like
24 xbox series x's here man yeah like
like this is ridiculous no one's buying
them
why are they here if you find a store
with xbox series x
stocked in the corner please let me know
[Laughter]
okay don't you think that because
they've been winning every month
and still beating these powerful systems
like what's gonna
it what's gonna empower them to do
listen here buddy
all the stock inflation that you're
doing the bottom is gonna fall out of
your market and you're gonna hit your
head on the floor
it's gonna happen it's gonna i can't
we've been waiting for a year
now these these dudes have been slowing
other ones have been slowing down
mm-hmm they have no games so i'm gonna
keep it a buck with those dudes no games
for you
that are really dudes that don't got no
games
so because they don't have nothing
compelling for you the rest of the world
does not matter
i had to stop you there no holidays
so last year right i don't think i
booted that switch one time
right and they won everything every
other pc they clearly are not going
to y'all demographic they know whatever
it is it's waiting
they are not absolutely like you know
what
there isn't well except for youtube
dudes
there's no second purchasing i'm not
buying the standstill
and i don't care this ain't gonna be a
standstill i'm gonna tell you right now
this they've hit their their mid gen
they've hit their [ __ ] for the switch
right that's why
a lot of the stuff that i see in this
data mine like the oled screen
yeah they're not giving us that they're
not giving us that
i can see look i can see 1080p i can see
that
i can see the up clock tegra chip to
make it a little faster
i can see a brighter screen i could see
even better battery life
those are the types of improvements that
they make we're not going to get the
quality look
we're not going to be part of the life
stuff they're not doing nothing
through the 4k which would be bonkers to
me they do the 4k
it would be in the dock if they do the
4k
the king like 4k the 4k would still
happen
the 4k would still have to incorporate
the old machine like
they already made the mistake of making
the machine
that only played certain games yo what
if they what of yours
never says nintendo is the tc uh the tlc
of gaming
what if what if what if what if did you
know how when you get too high on your
own supply right
what if what if right now they their
heads are floating in the cloud name
like yo
let's drop that new console right and
they drop a whole new console
with the whole new dock it's not even a
dock it's a
it's a console it's for the living room
because we already got the switch like
they did the ds
we already got that and we can make
games for that and this is nintendo's
new foray
into the next generation not even though
mid gen refresh
this is not a pro this is just a
full-blown console
that can actually play stuff what if
they bumped their head
i mean they said it's still going to
have the component of listen
look at when i was on brat recently we
talked about this no one talked about
this like and people were like
forte was like nah there's no way but
like me and slow ball were like
look this is nintendo we're talking
about like
they can look at the numbers and like
we're doing fantastically throw that in
the bushes yeah
this is what they do because the thing
is with the switch right
with the switch you're assuming that
they looked
at what went wrong with the wii u and
and
looked at the market and they were like
okay where do we fit in here right
you're assuming that's what they did
rather than just be like yo the switch
was the natural evolution of the wii u
we were coming out with this
anyway whether we were in the bushes or
not right so if that is the case
and the switch was just the natural
evolution from the wii u they weren't
looking at their place in the market
they weren't looking where they were
failing
it was just this is what it was going to
be then it stands to reason
that the next thing could come out of
left field and they could throw the
switch straight in the bushes because
pretty much the wii u
was just what they wanted the wii uh
they wanted the switch to be but they
didn't have the technology they didn't
have the tech yet
they didn't have the key will be if
because they have so
much success would they bump their head
to do
something to be honest with you
to be honest with you i think there's
zero chance that they
they lose
i don't care about all those mpd wins we
made a new toy here you go
yeah there isn't like they control it
with your eyeballs
at the end of the day so at the end of
the day they
they so they sell cardboard people
exactly
yes and no
it's sold out it may still be sold out
and it doesn't work right because
i only seen boom with it i said i don't
even know how the hell boom got one
[Laughter]
boom i tell you like i i wish
that it was hey man we're looking at
like and it's a new nintendo it could be
right there like the the
the the leadership over there is
different so maybe doug bowser sees
things differently but at the same time
everything
everything that matters is nintendo
right it comes out of
nintendo of japan like whatever the
temperature is gonna do that's what's
gonna get done
right exactly to me it is hilarious man
because it's like
we're speculating about this stuff i
would love a switch pro right
we would right for natural evolution we
would like the xbox one x of switches
we'll love that
i don't know
since nes to snes
they've never had back-to-back
successful consoles
this is the laws that i'm looking for so
why would they even want to update
upgrade clearly they're out selling
everything all their first parties out
selling everything the height for the
switch is probably
selling literally every month and you
know other games every month
it would only only really matter if
their
internal studios were starting to have
trouble making games
right they're gay they're games
one person inside nintendo
how can i kill this
look look the thing is though when it
comes
to what they've always been good at
that's handhelds
yeah this is a handheld they've never
had a miss when it comes to action
so they're gonna do oculus rift type of
joint right watch
they're gonna do some vr it's gonna be
the virtual boy
it's gonna be the virtual boy
you know i can see it man i would love
them to just be
do the logical correct thing to do and i
i just i'm afraid
[Music]
i get that but they've never dropped the
box of handhelds they're they're they're
toy makers you're gonna still be able to
buy a switch
but this is the thing though right they
don't they don't make pure handhelds
anymore now they have to consider both
markets right
so yes it would make sense that they
continue making hybrids because
that has worked for them but again that
is assuming
that they read the tea leaves going into
the nintendo switch and the switch came
out of them understanding that they were
getting asked
i don't know if that's the the reasoning
what if they do this right what if they
cut off
the og uh uh switch right they did that
leave the stand still because that's the
popular joint with all the colors right
the weaker one yeah right and then they
make a console
for the house because they already got
the switch for the streets which got a
lot of what is
and they just come out with this new
joint with the weird controller that
launches onto your fingers
they make they make something just for
the house we have shown
this one has a dock the rubber
[Music]
i think they're gonna keep riding the
success of the switch for at least
three four years i don't think we're
gonna get any significant changes we'll
get better battery life
[Music]
and maybe a little more juice but
nothing that's gonna
adversely affect games
and then in four years we get something
good at it as long as they have
mario kart pokemon and mario everything
else is in relevance i feel that i feel
it we we know how things go let me get
this get the super chat
i'm surprised lord king didn't bring up
the fact that vrr is not coming to sony
900
it's not oh no time listen
um i i was just going to tell you guys
if their tvs aren't supporting it you
can pretty much
know that the playstation 5 isn't going
to support it yet
when the update goes out for the
televisions then you will see the update
go out for the place
you know the thing about it is that they
promised that update to the 900 age
from the rip and they've been silent
about it
so um you know the the tech guys on
youtube have been
inquiring with something like what's
going on with this should have been
pat's like what what's going on
behind the scenes and i guess it's
trickled out that it's
not coming to the 900h that's the thing
so the problem there is that yo people
cop this tv
because play it with the playstation 5
like play it plays playstation 5 best
you know and
what playstation 5 apparently
playstation is offering you
so yeah so um time time
[Laughter]
wait you were up without having a bed at
that hour yeah he's up cutie come on
let's get this with you
hey we have victor alex here with the
five dollar super chat 2018 seven studio
acquisitions 2019 council reveal at ga
at game awards
2020 zenimax acquisition announced by
any guesses for 2021
isn't sonic enough to say yeah
we'll see
yeah we got rubber knob with the five
dollars
x cloud gonna hurt the switch but if
game pass comes on switch game
over yeah that is true they ain't doing
that fella ray said we can help them out
when they fall they
they too high on their own supply right
now they ain't listening to nobody
oh never got gaming 14 with the 5 super
chat
i might have to take king's knees again
i remember when he said animal crossing
wouldn't outsell avengers
nintendo will pass ps2 sales in three
years
yeah and then and avengers is in
this is nintendo's way but if their next
console does not play switch games with
the same cartridge it's a fail the
racetrack is fire i have two
they got two how do you get those
i mean let's keep going right here
while i was talking to you guys i was
gonna sit back and play with it
shaking my head nintendo will sell you a
cardboard crt
before they do that hold on then i gotta
go back oh that was it
that was it all right cool so look real
quick for me um yeah with the first part
with the next level um yeah i will
i will admit i was surprised because i
thought that um hold on let's get slow
uh ten thousand tesla backslap the
manatees that write the stories for
family guy
also executives that plan the next
console after nintendo makes a good one
next nintendo console is going to be
made out of paper mache
[Laughter]
which is the snatching victory what is
it what is it what is this
[Laughter]
but look for the next level i was
surprised because nintendo has not
copped
a studio in like 13 years yeah last one
was
the last one was yes monolith yeah it's
like violence so when i saw that i was
like
what y'all doing so i had to hit i was
going to kick up like
i wonder if like phil somebody slid the
dims
and was like yo what's up let me kick
the tires on this availability and
nintendo's like nah
we're not doing that because it just
seemed weird like they
like they've had this great relationship
they've made luigi's mansion strikers
all these nintendo games they don't need
to necessarily put a ring on that
but it's just funny to me that they they
had to do it now
like so to me it's like someone was
kicking around the towers like the hey
boo with the deal
they probably know they probably heard
that they were doing meetings with other
people
and they're like oh oh it's like that
it's like
nintendo is so used to people who bear
with them off the street
you don't think it's not just you know
nintendo has probably been thinking
about making that
that that push but they never done it
because they didn't have to
but then you have amazon poking around
yeah
that's that fear of god because you know
say what you will about ea right yeah
it's not
what they were or whatever the fact that
ea's in bed with game pads
i don't care what you say like and if
the ubisoft thing is true
that is the fear of god you need to you
need to get in bed with all these things
that's less like a mom you got to lock
your bull down
lock your movement
there's a reason they haven't bought
platinum but i think we all know that
oh phil dominic said you want me to take
you to the next level
no that luigi mansion you did what's
good
look at that really dude
man you know i don't know what they're
gonna do all i want like i said
4k or whatever okay we see that's
the integra man integra that's what i
want to know get the tiger up get your
tigers up
get your cpu popping you know what i'm
saying give me some frames before you
worry about all this 4k and stuff
and get it proper online please and let
me message people
that's why i like it i don't care about
all this other stuff it's cool that's
great
that's it but um yeah man that's all i
got
anybody else so we can roll on out of
here cause atticus is in the bushes
so i'm here okay so look new ilp
pole we're gonna get a chance to touch
my show on this but in the show but
we're gonna touch on it now
which what if game scenario would have
been the most
impactful on the game industry in an
alternate reality hey this is one of the
rumors that went on that just came out
nintendo being purchased by microsoft
during the og xbox era i know y'all
caught that article
b sony and nintendo combining forces to
actually make playstation
c sega and sony secret cd
console talks this was going on right at
the same time that nintendo
and sony fell through or d i don't care
activision or ea need to buy wb games
[Laughter]
that is the question those rock the vote
man please check that out later on
twitter salute the lord mark nada from
firaxis games pull it up
good show and of course the realm
showing tremendous support
lord addict about to be in the bushes
for not getting no sleep and he's on the
phone
but he's going to ask him where can i
find him to find him but he's on the
phone so we're going to ask saw wicked
if i can find him
oh yeah first off yeah check me out on
the big cast this week and shout out to
ames
and and lord dan and the indie gamer um
fantastic to be on there and of course
you can find me at lordstop iop
on twitter let me say it differently you
know that i don't get called out by
adding
um and you know where i'm going yeah you
know
back to work doing his
thing y'all buddy no addict's still on
the phone lord king pushing game pass
agendas to firaxis games i'm gonna tell
you right now we need it for access and
to get purchased we need them to get
purchased
i think they're with 2k 2k that's nice
so we need to snatch them
available kick the tires over there
because you know 2k
ain't using them how they're supposed to
oh they're getting exposure how they
supposed to
but yo you can catch me on dolph castlex
luscious statues like this being unboxed
yeah yeah just turn it over this way oh
the
display the setup you see anubis in the
back that kos is dropping on monday kos
dropped this week with hulk
transformation
which is right here um right after that
we're going to uh go
into scarlet witch which is over there
and we're going to get into that red
hawk which is a monster
nice this whole time i've been um
texting and and talking to guys uh
because i put a couple of statues up for
sale like i changed my whole direction
into xm statues so uh yeah those statues
is up for sale most of them is already
just sold already
uh i put up like 10 and they all gone um
almost and um i'm going to be bringing
different and new content in
because i'm ordering i just take that
money and revolve it right back into new
statues
so you catch me on twitter king david
otw
also on uh xbox live king david otw same
thing
we're rubbing up
i saw i was sitting there and he
[Laughter]
[Music]
because when i'm on dude's jumping a
party and it's it's cool like when i was
playing with cog
and we was we were actually you know i
wasn't playing with cogwhees in the chat
and some dude just jumped into my game
when i was playing i guess he swore me
on
he was like yo i'ma join king and play
with king but he didn't see nothing in
the chat
but it's it's whatever man we out here
we're real human beings we
our heads are not big paws uh we
definitely um
neil said wow you must be making good
money
oh man okay i'm out
yeah i'm back all right cool lord addict
where can the five people find you what
you got going on follow me on twitter
lord addicts iop you can find me on
youtube at gaming addicts
and you can find me going to work here
in about 20 minutes
oh man i see you like that wonder woman
though neil said he was gonna
help you get kick his clear
how long is this raid now that you guys
got it down pat like how
long we can do it 45 45 minutes okay so
you you know your way through the fall
that's if no one messes up yeah yeah you
get to a part where people brain fart
[Music]
now we good we good so all right we got
that and of course you already know
little cognito here sorry no last word
this weekend
um like i said uh ease has been having a
ton of problems with this provider so
we're gonna work on some backup
solutions
most likely iop channel if that happens
again if he doesn't get his stuff
resolved because the last word must
continue must get that destiny talk on
that song loves to hear
and um tomorrow
yeah what'd you say is it tomorrow
yeah i gotta get that out of the ball
we'll have to get that popping hopefully
if attic is not too tired
or maybe later on we can get a rain on
it late night i'll take that for that
because i want to get carried by addict
and the crew
so that's all i gotta get salute uh mark
donald we got a lot of fun guests
hooking up this month a lot of things
playing a lot of big stuff be on the
lookout for the next two months it's
gonna be crazy appreciate
the salutes everybody we miss any super
chats we're good
yeah we're good all right man we're
gonna get out oh wait wait wait wait
wait no no we have to go
here we go good all right cool everybody
yo why racist said king's not releasing
his tax
info cause he under y'all y'all pocket
watching my man anyways
anyway on that note everybody enjoying
jake
we see y'all next green screen next week
the green screen next week
block all of that
[Music]
hmm
[Music]
[Music]
bye